[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
hey everybody what's going on
that's where I got Medusa and we have
Bane from Santa prisca
yeah I'm I'm very very blind right now
because like I said I have to wear
glasses like to see the screen
um so the screen's like a blur but I was
like well I didn't want to bring glasses
because Medusa didn't wear glasses not
that we know of anyway yeah this is uh
what I wore to the club the other day I
posted the quick video
it was okay video the [ __ ] [ __ ] the
shadow wasn't that good but it um you
know I posted it in [ __ ] Tom shitty
movies a couple days back put it posted
on Instagram and stuff I don't think
Jenny's posted a single photo of what
she's wearing well no because I didn't
want to ruin it now I did take some
pictures today but I took some pictures
like before I went out Saturday night
it's like I don't know some things I
liked better about the makeup I did
Saturday night and some things I like
better about this one this one I got
like a little bit more scale detail
because what I got like a um
what do you call it uh like a little
template thing or like a stencil that's
what I'm that's the word I'm trying to
think of I got a stencil of like snake
skin and it's cool but like I couldn't
like I already like built up a lot of
the layers of makeup and then like you
couldn't really see it all that good and
I figured that it was kind of and I
didn't have time like I was watching
this one girl's tutorial and she had
that too but she sat there and like
painstakingly traced around like the
scales with white and I was like [ __ ]
ain't no one got time for that so I just
kind of like but so this time I just
kind of like did the green and then put
a fishnet over my face and then just
kind of went around like that but you
probably still can't really see it I
can't see because everything is blurry
so yeah and I'm not gonna be able to
wear uh the [ __ ] Bane mask yeah like
I said I'm gonna drink I'm gonna be all
right yeah
I was like I was like next year I either
need to get Lasik eye surgery or I need
to have a mat have a costume that
incorporates glasses yes so it doesn't
look stupid like because even like
before the show started because I mean
starting at two hours earlier was a good
idea but I was like scrambling you know
what I mean because I had to start
getting ready like two and a half hours
ago because this takes a long time but I
mean luckily I'd already done it once I
did it Saturday so I kind of knew what
the drill was uh but still like the
makeup took a long time because it's
very very layered and stuff what's she
doing
I fell asleep on her [ __ ] stomach oh
my God
she's like hilarious that little that
little Philly girl so yeah so I can't
really see anybody's comments yet until
I put the glasses oh it's looking uh
they're saying Nacho Libre and Duck and
uh El Santo no it's Bane
it's it's the old Bane or Bane from the
DC excuse me from the Marvel comic books
yeah and some of the both the comic book
vein maybe that should be your job you
can read me the comments yeah I can't
really I don't I can't move my glasses
so I can't really see either hold on
okay there you go how about that oh
I hate not being able to see I hate it
murder Hornet says Tom is uh demastered
I can't I can't really understand what
that says I can't really read it uh
[ __ ] Jeffy heart says you guys look
awesome have Halloween yeah happy
Halloween guys you guys look amazing
and uh murder says Thomas is the Santos
Jenny your makeup looks fantastic thank
you
and the grafters is going Nacho Libre
okay the nails love them
yeah I want to show you the nails yeah
and she's got contacts on show her that
look at the cut she's got green snake
eye contacts
look into the little camera there there
you go
I'm not sure yeah
yeah they're cool but I've noticed that
I'm like I said I'm real shitty at like
putting contact lenses in yeah and you
put them in and like they have a
tendency because they're supposed to be
like you know snake slits like up and
down uh but they have a tendency to like
kind of go like that so like sometimes
like at the end of the night I noticed
like when I came home the other day like
one of them was sideways
because it like turned around like
during the night oh well but I'm not
gonna stick my finger in my eyeball like
well that's the thing too is that
um when I came home from the club
Saturday night like I said it was like 3
30 or something and I was like oh [ __ ] I
have to take these contact lenses out
and I still have these nails on and
obviously I can't take contact lenses
out with the nails in so I'd like sit
there and like sped all this time like
prying them off so this time I only put
like one dot of blue it's because like
as soon as the show's over I'll take
them off or well as soon as you know
Pookie does not understand masks she's
back there why do they look like that
she's like what's the matter with you
guys although she wasn't like weirded
out I thought she was going to be
weirded out by the costume like when I
first did it Saturday but she was just
like whatever she thought like the
snakes and stuff were neat like she just
kind of was like yeah but like like oh
what's that dangly thing but like other
than that she was like meh I guess I
smell the same I'm still mama so you
still sound the same and we still sound
the same she's like what's all that [ __ ]
on your head why are their heads like
that
but yeah but uh yeah so people are still
coming in okay yeah I know I know it's
like weird that we started early it's
weird for us too and like I said I was
rushing I mean because I had other [ __ ]
I had to do this morning and I was like
[ __ ] rushing around and then I was
like doing the makeup and I was like
holy [ __ ] it's like 3 15 and
I had to put all the hair on and all
that kind of stuff but you know it's not
that much it's just um
this is like actually a dreadlock wig
and it's not a Medusa wig it's uh it's
called Zombie rocker actually
um I just got it because I wanted a
dreadlock one because I liked the
you know the juxtaposition between like
the dreadlocks and the snakes and uh the
only other dreadlock one they had was
like reddish and I was like well that
doesn't really go with the whole theme
so I found this zombie one and it was
like kind of grayish green and I was
like yeah I'll be into that and then
like I just bought these little rubber
snakes and then like put them
they're just like attached to this thing
which is just almost like a rubber band
or something which is nice because this
is just plastic so it's like super light
but it has a tendency to like scoot down
your head
but that's okay that's kind of where
it's supposed to go anyway I guess
like on your forehead and at least I
didn't have to like do all the makeup on
my forehead so there's that
now I'm gonna have to go yeah whoa Jay
it's the attention to detail
[Laughter]
yeah I mean well I figure look I love
Halloween it's my favorite and I figure
if I'm gonna dress up I'm gonna go all
out I'm not gonna like you know cheap
out on the [ __ ] I'm not just gonna be
like oh no one will notice that or
notice I'm like I'll notice you know
what I mean yeah I like I like to go all
out with it yeah we're probably gonna
hand out some candy too
yeah whenever if we get into kids this
year yeah I think we'll get some yeah
yeah yeah I hope so I mean like I said
it's only four I'm glad we started early
but but like I said it's kind of a
little bit discombobulating Yeah because
like I said I had to start getting ready
at like 1 30.
and even and even then I didn't make it
I almost didn't make it because I was
like just like 20 minutes ago I was
sitting there like sticking the nails
I'm like oh my God my fingernails are
sticking to my fingers are sticking
together and [ __ ] like that but you know
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do
but does it look like on camera like I
said I can't release like it looks good
it looks good to me but but everything
looks good to me because it's all blurry
I'm like in soft focus yeah
and you know and it was a little bit
easier too because it doesn't have to be
like live action yeah I got very little
sleep last night very little yeah
um
I get in and go back to sleep this
morning like you said you were going to
I went back I probably didn't fall back
to sleep until maybe eight
7 30 maybe eight around that time yeah
but then he's gonna get up until later
in the afternoon though did you yeah I
got up about an hour ago maybe yeah so
uh I don't know probably four or five
hours but that was night time yeah
you can sleep during the day I can't it
was [ __ ] miserable like once the sun
comes up I'm like well I'm awake
even if I only had like an hour or two
of sleep I don't know why I can't sleep
during the day I just can't yeah I don't
know even in a dark room there's
something about it that's my what do you
call it circadian clock or yeah whatever
me it's all coming off that [ __ ]
I know yeah [ __ ] man my [ __ ] mind's
[ __ ] up is that warp myself all
[ __ ] night
I had I didn't I wasn't really prepared
for it I had to look at the literature
and went oh okay
it was because of what it was that I
took and [ __ ] this and that uh and it
was the first time you kind of almost
have something like withdrawal symptoms
from it because your [ __ ] levels are
going way up all the way down to there
and your your body's like where'd that
go
and then you know you're [ __ ]
emotional state gets [ __ ] crazy man
I'm [ __ ] I'm on a rag
basically yeah Jay goes oh yeah women
are always like that
well I don't like the way he's
describing like the way the thoughts
that he's having and the feelings that
he's having like so like women all the
time yeah I'm like I feel like that all
the time
going from way up there to down here and
all of a sudden you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and [ __ ] it's not so much I mean I I
don't want people to think that it's
like it's not so much being a [ __ ] it's
like it's other things it's like it's
kind of like anxiety and paranoia yeah
and distorted distorted views on what's
Happening you're not sure what's true or
if you're just more if you're making it
up or not or if it's just like your
feelings well that's what I mean like
that's very that's something that we
deal with all the time man well that's
what I mean well and that's kind of one
of the things too that I think like
women like find frustrating about men is
that they just kind of like blunder
through life like not even thinking
about it but um but women aren't like
that because we're always kind of like
second guessing ourselves like wait was
that like that person that made that
comment is like they just made that
innocently or is that a backhand account
yeah that's yeah that's what you like
like or something like that like it's
cut you're constantly like questioning
yourself and you're questioning your own
perceptions and I was like yeah so yeah
at least you said it's funny because you
said Sophie said that too yeah and
actually um I was talking to Jen the
other like at Memento not this last time
but last time before and um I was saying
that like you were you know you were
having like all these like emotional
issues because of the [ __ ] uh drugs
and everything and she said oh so like
being a woman all the time and I was
like yeah
she said it too she's like you know
Demetrius yeah okay she's like yeah we
feel like that all the time I'm like I
know
no I understand it I understand it now
yeah maybe and maybe it's like I don't
mean to be an ass but maybe that's why
I'm not like all that sympathetic
because I'm just kind of like yeah
welcome to the club
the other stuff that I took the other
Peds that I took [ __ ] they were
[ __ ] awesome just you feel positive
and uh it's just sunshine and [ __ ]
positivity unicorns farting rainbow
unicorns and every [ __ ] thing you
know what I mean
but this one you know this one's like
the Mount Everest of them [ __ ] Trend
alone it's got a [ __ ] horrible
reputation
for doing that and I said well I gotta
do it it's a lot of bang for the buck
it's fast and it everybody else does it
and a lot of people if everyone else
jumped off don't do that yeah don't do
that one you know but [ __ ] uh yeah
don't do that one
that wasn't really quite worth it yeah I
could have done that with yeah more
pleasant [ __ ] it would have taken a
little bit more time and more money but
go that way go that route don't don't go
the [ __ ] Trend baloney sandwich way
that's that is a way of paying and
suffering and darkness I said tell me
about it what's that I said tell me
about it yeah no I don't know welcome to
my world no you'll understand welcome to
the inside of my brain you'll understand
why women are crazy
we're not crazy we just see the world
the difference I saw it I saw it yeah I
saw it well and I told them I told him
this morning I said well maybe this will
make you like more empathetic towards
yeah because now that you know what
we're going through all the time yeah
like honestly I kind of think and this
is why like this is a very general but
this is why honestly I think in general
I think women are like a lot emotionally
like stronger like more resilient
because they're dealing with that [ __ ]
all the time and they still have to like
function they still have to like get up
and go to work and like raise kids and
do whatever the [ __ ] else you gotta do
and you can't like whine too much about
it so you know you just have to like put
on your big girl pants and kind of like
deal with it you know to put it in
perspective it's not as mind-altering as
say like LSD it's not like that
and that almost makes it worse because
it's more Insidious you're not sure if
it's really happening you know what I
mean without SD you know that's
happening you're on a trip
this you got to read up on it man if I
didn't read up on this [ __ ] and know
what to expect before it happened I
would have thought I was going crazy
but I was prepared for it yeah I didn't
know that there was kind of like a mild
withdrawal symptom from it but it only
lasts a couple days the dudes didn't
mention it
some guys mention it but you got to look
for that
um
it's uh imagine okay if you're a dude a
woman not instantly would know what it
is we're talking well yeah like I said
as soon as I talk to like everybody that
I know that was female they're like yeah
so like us all the time I'm like yeah
exactly what it is is that it's a weird
combination
it doesn't really happen in men or women
naturally
your [ __ ] testosterone levels would
be [ __ ] spiked up for
six weeks to eight weeks depending on
how long you're doing it it'll be spiked
up way high probably like [ __ ] four
or five times what a [ __ ]
badass 20 year old would be
then you're estrogen levels are down in
the dirt which that's bad on a man too
because it
it does it prevents you from getting
good sleep that's one of the things that
it does it does a lot of stuff to you it
kind of wears at you not having that and
then your progesterone levels are real
high and men don't have high
progesterone levels that's like a
pregnant woman thing or a you know or or
it's more of a woman thing
so you have this weird [ __ ]
combination of your Superman and you're
[ __ ] pregnant at the same time
pregnant Superman and you're on your
[ __ ] someone's fetish what it's like
well you can't be pregnant on your
period whatever it's just it's not
enough whatever whatever it's something
[ __ ] weird I forgot his basic
violence it's not supposed to happen in
a man okay so what it ends up doing is
is that you have this weird situation
where you feel [ __ ] super powerful
and Godlike on one hand but on the other
hand you're extremely insecure and
you're not sure if you're [ __ ]
thinking is right and all your
confidence is being sucked away which
that doesn't mean that that sounds
[ __ ] insane because it is how could
you have Godlike confidence
and then have all your confidence sucked
away it's kind of pulsing a little bit
yeah I'm very I'm I'm aware of that
emotion yeah I have that too you have
that too all the time yeah well [ __ ]
men don't have that I mean every now
like someday you wake up and be like man
I'm awesome I can do all this kind of
stuff I never feel Superior to other
people maybe other people oh no I was
feeling Superior no I never do that but
like I said that might be something that
is because it's different it happens in
that hormone but then like later like a
few like hours later I'll be like man I
suck yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
it's like yeah your balls to the walls
and then slamming the brakes on balls to
the wall slamming the brakes on it it
might happen I was noticing that
because I was injecting every three days
day one of the injection you felt great
day two you started to question yourself
day three your breaks were [ __ ] full
on even though it might
pulse and then you're gonna inject again
which you come back so it's this
constant roller coaster and it's all
emotion
which is weird because dudes don't
really [ __ ] experience
guys don't really have a [ __ ] broad
emotional Spectrum most of the time when
they're healthy
they're just it's pretty narrow band
guys are consistent pretty much
it's hard to [ __ ] them up takes a long
time to [ __ ] up anger sleepiness anger
sleeping is a hunger and sex yeah that's
pretty much none of that other [ __ ] it
interesting
introspection you know what I mean well
like I said chatting yourself now do you
understand why we find you so much
you're worried about what other
[ __ ] think we don't give a [ __ ]
about that you know it's just you know
it's just so you're kind of like
clinically insane a little bit and so a
lot of times I've spent it I was when I
was feeling bad I go hide
you know I'm gonna go hide you gotta go
hide yeah and [ __ ]
it was really worse at night
because you can't sleep
yeah because those you can but it's not
good sleep you never really enter when
I'm REM sleep
and when I came off of it I was like oh
I feel better and then three days later
[ __ ] it got worse
because it's gone now you kind of got
used to that feeling it's weird
about time looks like everybody's here
is it almost time to start the I mean
yeah we could uh
uh Daniel Rowling said Tom tell Jenny to
stand up so we can get a look at her
whole costume there's not much more to
it it's just like the bottom of a toga
it does have like a little bit see I did
like a little bit of a belt that also
has a snake it's a black Toge
like a like a Greek no it's like a black
Greek dress yeah and then I got this
bracelet too and she doesn't have her
her boots on
well yeah I was like she should have to
sit here because I'm sitting here anyway
so it's like I'm about to put the book
because you know because I like to sit I
like to sit like um cross-legged in my
chair because I'm a child like that
I don't well it's because I got used to
it because I'm short
and so like sometimes some chairs I sit
in like my feet don't quite reach the
floor and it's like a lot more
comfortable to put them in my lap so I
just got used to doing that you know
what I mean
but yeah so what else like I said I hate
to have to put the glasses on because it
kind of like ruins the look but you know
yeah uh Hugo said I've been missing your
show lately this is my busiest month of
the year yeah same it's like I kind of
feel bad because I know last year I did
um like extra Halloween themed like
movie reviews like I did each week and I
was gonna do that again this year but I
just didn't have time to do it I didn't
have time to do it because like I said I
started like two more channels and
all that other kind of stuff and I
wanted to do actually today
um I found a recipe for there's like a
pumpkin pie martini essentially
uh using that whipped cream vodka
and I was like oh I think we have
everything for that but it's like we
were just like scrambling to
start it and I think all it was it's
whipped cream vodka pumpkin puree
pumpkin spice and one other thing
and then you can put like graham cracker
crust like around the outside if you
want to but it sounded really good
anyway oh and half and half that's the
other thing I knew it was only like four
ingredients then you kind of like blend
it all together but yeah
so
oh well when he says okay I'm gonna go
ahead and take my mask off
so I can read what the hell's going on
and we're gonna start the show really
somebody gave us some money no that's
great
let's see let me see where it's at yeah
it's hard to like get this on thank you
Aaron thank you
said you look amazing Jenny thank you
very much thank you very much I was very
excited to I only decided like a couple
weeks ago
yeah well you had the mask on
you have the mask on so
yeah it was like really I you know like
I said but I bought all the stuff for
the costume because this isn't all one
thing it's like all separate pieces
because they are they do have like
store-bought like Medusa costumes that
you can just buy like off the rack not
with the makeup and all that obviously
but one that comes with all the [ __ ]
and I looked at some of those and it's
like I don't know there was some like
pieces I didn't like of one thing and I
was like well I'm really like that or I
don't really like like I don't like the
dress or I don't like the headpiece or I
don't like whatever so I said well I'm
just gonna get like separate pieces and
put some [ __ ] together myself and then
I'd so I didn't know like how it was
gonna work out lane was asking me what
were you what were you taking if you
don't mind me asking I was taking the
Holy Trinity
test propionate which that's not a
problem
masteron which that's not really a big
problem
the one that really gets you was in that
stack was Trend alone
trenblone's not really a proof for human
use it's a cattle steroid
it doesn't it's it's very inexpensive it
does a lot of work in a short period of
time
it's very mentally disturbing I do not
recommend it
there are some dudes that love it that
don't have any problem with it that's
their genetics most people don't you can
take it it's not real well tolerated
injection sites real painful
your legs always [ __ ] sore or stiff
uh you never really big goose eggs form
in it it's just
sometimes I'll have a [ __ ] flat spot
you could press it in it's like a big
flat sheet of [ __ ] it's just weird
it's so gross it's all good she touched
it she's like God that's nasty but it's
it's still gross Tom yeah your body
doesn't really know
for a while it takes your body a while
to realize that oh okay I know what this
is for
so it's just weird [ __ ] that happens is
your body's being like this is for cows
yeah what are you doing
it does weird [ __ ] tea at first and then
you kind of get get used to it and then
that goes away and then weirdest [ __ ]
happens like
you think your [ __ ] girlfriend's
cheating on you and you know she's not
that's not possible yeah like I said but
they that's a con you've got to read up
on all that [ __ ] before you start
because it's gonna yeah you're good with
somebody that lives in the Attic crawl
space like I never go anywhere yeah
but you you mentally prepare yourself
for it it's it's this kind of the same
thing all them cows are out there
[ __ ] accusing each other
but oh my God it's like a Far Side
you just don't know because they can't
talk
yeah they could be all kind of they
could be all kind of yeah I'm I'm of the
opinion that I think animals have a much
richer inner life than we have ever
given them credit for you don't know
what this I you know you can tell like
some shit's going on in pokey's little
mind all the time yeah she's like she's
really smart and you can tell like what
she's thinking like by her facial
expressions and like the way she's
acting and [ __ ] and she imagines she can
imagine things we've seen her do it so
why can't a cow do it
you know okay now Elaine says I hurt a
lot of people
uh have mixed opinion on Trend about to
hit some d-ball test cycle soon as I get
some PCT yeah okay d-ball I like d-ball
you retain a lot of water on it uh
d-ball is like really good test it makes
you walk around with a [ __ ] chubby
all right [ __ ] you you're gonna want
to hit some [ __ ] all right I don't know
how old you are you better have a
[ __ ] supply of [ __ ] Viagra because
uh you're gonna be kind of frustrated
when you're going to want to just
tear your girlfriend down or I don't
know maybe I don't know maybe you have a
boyfriend I don't know what your
orientation is but uh because oh they
got gay bodybuilders no really but
anyway um everybody knows that yeah the
uh you're gonna try to tear it down and
you're not going to be able to [ __ ]
rock it up because your [ __ ] sex
drive will outrun your dick
you'll just go on a funny mental image
though yeah that's what it is I just
imagined a little dick with legs like
running yeah
that's how my mind works yeah I was like
okay detachable pain yeah you'll knock
it down and [ __ ] and then you're like
two minutes later you want to do it
again but you're just not ready but you
just refuse to
wait you know but d-ball was good I like
the d-ball just um
um
I like the injectable I did uh pills
they say it retains a lot of water I've
never tried them but the injectable most
people like it I'd recommend injectable
uh you inject [ __ ] every day just a
small amount it was like 15 milligrams
or 20 milligrams I think a day 15 I
think it was so and
um you want to have like a six week
cycle and uh
you said you PCT you're gonna use Clomid
or HCG when you come off of it
um
if you're on HRT or just taking tests
like I'm gonna take tests to the Grave
because I'm so old I don't really make a
good enough amount of tests anyway I
started off in a HRT Clinic there's no
reason for me to ever come off HRT so
that's why it just opens a Gateway you
know you can say well if I can gonna
take this for the rest of my life might
as well just put the good [ __ ] on top of
it too every now and then [ __ ] spice
it up some
but if you're just going to be on HRT
you won't need PCT
just stay on HRT
for those of you guys don't know we're
talking about if you're taking tests and
you're going to live on test because
you've only got 30 40 years left of in
your lifespan there's no reason to come
off of it all right uh so you don't need
to recovery time off of steroids you
just stop taking them you're taking
tests so there's no hormonal crash
you're immune to that now
so uh but I do not recommend going on
HRT
yeah you do no I do not recommend it
until you hit at least 35 between 35 and
40. know what I know now I would have
gone on at 40. instead I think I went on
around 7 50 didn't I
uh yeah I think I went on to 50. yeah no
I would have gone on at 40. you know now
know now
probably would have gained a few years
on my lifespan
because it avoids other damage
all right so let me hook up glasses on
for a second because you know it's
Halloween October said you can wear your
glasses it still looks cool well I just
wanted to make sure everybody got the
full effects before I have to put
glasses on now I'm like smart Medusa
yeah okay
um Lane
and the other guy's talking about how
hardcore that was when it comes to trend
I don't think it's worth it you could I
could have done it with a more milder
compound it just would have taken a
little bit longer a bit a lot more
enjoyable but what trend does is it
gives you a certain shape
it can kind of give you a freaky shape
pretty quick
not so much size you'll gain size but
you'll gain that on other things too but
what I have noticed is that
it accentuates shape pretty well
if you're already really big
I don't think it'd do much to you other
than just maybe give you a little bit
more definition
if you were small a beginner I wouldn't
touch it with a 10 foot pole it's too
harsh for you
if you're in the middle like a mid
middle part of your development
if you want to do a little cycle it's on
you I don't recommend it but I did it
I wouldn't do it again though I don't
think no
no I do win straw win strong test
Dave Rowling said what does Medusa and
marijuana have in common they both can
get you stoned yeah see if I was really
Medusa every single one of you watching
this would be turning to Stone right now
I actually saw like kind of a cool
couple's costume that somebody like the
girl dressed like Medusa and her
boyfriend dresses like he did like um he
did a toga and stuff too but then he did
like half
Stone like he was half made of marble it
looked really cool
um oh I wanted to say before I got too
far into it because uh Aaron reminded me
by sending sending a Super Chat is that
we have a new Patron
after all this time like master of
dungeons so thank you very much if
you're out there that's our newest
Patron I just got the message today so
we haven't had a new patreon in a long
time
we've mostly just had our same ones you
know what I mean which we love and
appreciate all of our patrons but you
know it's always nice to get a new one
always nice to get a new one yeah thank
you for uh joining the family yeah uh
somebody paid us for a shirt I think it
was a girl and I forgot who it was
if you guys ordered a shirt for because
you never sent us a drag message with
your size but I remember in the chat
room
a girl sent us some money for a shirt
yeah I feel well sometimes like well
like I said if sometimes because I tell
people like send me a direct message but
sometimes I don't know if I don't get
them or they go to like junk mail or I
don't really know yeah send the direct
message on messenger or [ __ ] uh
Instagram or something for not Instagram
because I don't usually check that I
mean I do kind of and actually now that
Facebook has that I haven't quite
figured it out yet but now Facebook has
this like business suite and it has like
all of your uh business pages and in
theory uh it also sends your Instagram
messages to Facebook so it's all like
integrated but I don't know it always I
don't know if it always works out
because sometimes I get like
sometimes I get stuff and sometimes I
don't you know what I mean sometimes I
see it sometimes I don't
but that's all that's all
I don't know I think this looks dumb
with the glasses but I can't see without
it
don't worry about it just I know but
it's like you know how I you know how I
do you know how I get like all
like I said I even put these [ __ ]
Nails on and everything
like can you run can you run the mouse
and run all this um well I can run the
mouse it's like the it's kind of hard to
like type [ __ ]
it's my own fault like I do this [ __ ] to
myself but like I said if I'm gonna do a
costume I want to like [ __ ]
I want to do it right you know what I
mean I want to like do it up I like all
the details I like all that kind of
stuff I don't like to half-ass it I was
like on the way home from
uh from mannequin Saturday I was I was
saying the time I was like I'm not sure
because like I said I love Halloween and
I'm not really sure I was like which is
worse like somebody that doesn't make
any effort at all like to dress up
they're just wearing like some [ __ ]
cargo shorts and a polo shirt and Crocs
or something or somebody that does make
an effort but then like just half-asses
it
you know I'm not really sure like what
what pisses me off more I I'm
a real big fan of joke costumes we did
see kind of like a lot of because
mannequins it was just like everybody
like I said it was [ __ ] mobbed on
Saturday night and actually they decided
they were gonna do a night to tonight
too like just at the last minute they're
like hey would anybody come if we did a
night tonight and everybody was like
yeah and I was like oh my God I can't
afford that but um
so tired
yeah we could but it's like everybody
already saw this costume by the way and
it's like I don't have time to like
throw it together another one you know
how to get but I mean yeah I do already
have the costume I'm gonna make the I'm
gonna make the other band costume for
next year the other main costume yeah
the Tom Hardy Bane I know I say this
every year but I'm just kind of like I
was like oh now I need to start like
thinking about what I'm gonna do like
next year but it's like I always do that
and then like it's and then I'm like oh
[ __ ] it's like October already and I
haven't thought of anything good but I
have to like a very specific
like like I was saying before it's like
I have a whole taxonomy of like and you
know no offense if like people like
different things but it's like I
personally I don't like joke costumes
and I don't like pun costumes because I
feel like there's a whole like subset
and they sell them like at Spirit
Halloween and everything like that it's
like you know it's like just the dumb
it's usually like kind of bro type dudes
that have the that buy these kind of uh
costumes it's like look I'm a banana or
look I'm a hot dog or look I'm like a
doctor with that or like a you know
medical gown with like an ass sticking
out the back or some [ __ ] like that it's
like I don't like stuff like that I
don't like
um
costumes where you're just wearing like
a uniform or something like look I'm
like it's a baseball uniform you know
what I mean I'm like
it's not really a costume though not
really you know what I mean I don't know
I'm just kind of like one of those
people I like
I like monstery [ __ ] I like horror [ __ ]
I'm like it's Halloween like make it
scary I don't like I don't like funny
[ __ ] I don't know we did see this one
girl that had like
they do make a a sexy Chucky costume
because we saw the girl at mannequins
that had I guess that was sexy Chucky
right she was Chucky right yeah she was
she was sexy yeah but I'm just saying
though I'm like that's a weird costume
to like make sexy though yeah
it was three or four I think it was four
a little short
curvy Latina girls and one of them was
Chucky which I thought that was a cute
outfit they're real she had like a
little like a denim jumper yeah and they
were they were short and like the little
stripy shirt and she had like a big
knife and was like waving it around and
they were fake they were like spandex
yeah it was just printed to look like a
jumper
oh I think it might have had things like
cuffs on the you know and yeah I did
yeah it was kind of it was a spandex
real form-fitting and they they all had
nice little South American type figures
if you don't they're bootylicious all of
them and they were out there [ __ ]
twerking and [ __ ] and they had that one
there was a and they were all the same
size they're all yeah they were all
little they're all five feet tall and
all in there probably late 20s early 30s
they're probably late 20s like mid late
20s I think like I said I couldn't see
them all like that I had a Chucky
they had uh um what was the other girl
Wednesday actually Wednesday Adams yeah
yeah and it had a and then what was the
third one
there was two more oh okay there was two
more uh the other one was um
but they those costumes were all from
the same company you could tell they
they all went in and got them and all
became I think the other one was like uh
was it um Beetlejuice
Beetlejuice demon
hmm I don't think so there were a lot of
Beetlejuice themed costumes this year I
noticed I wonder why yeah oh wait a
minute wait a minute no one wasn't one
of them from uh the the thing from
Scream
what ghost face the ghost face wasn't
ghost face one of them or no no it was
[ __ ] like that it was real
um kind of generic not generic but just
real mainstream yeah that's it oh that's
right no Jason wasn't one of them with
Jason
maybe but I didn't see that one I
remember I only remember the Chucky one
in the Wednesday I don't remember the
other ones Freddy Krueger was maybe
think one of them was Freddy Krueger but
they were all like had like sexy
versions yeah which I always think is
like fairly funny yeah I thought it was
cute though I mean it's cute on some
people but it's like I don't know just
the concept is like funny to me I guess
look I'm sexy Freddy Krueger I'm like
okay yeah it's obviously like some
stripper would wear you're a sexy burned
child molester yeah
I thought it was funny
I wasn't the only one looking now the
guys were looking well yeah I don't I'm
not saying that I'm just saying I find
the concept of like sexy horror costumes
kind of funny well that's like not that
I don't know it depends it depends I
like I said I have kind of like a
a small window like ever since I was a
kid I was even when I was little you
know because how like sometimes like
little girls when they're grown-ups
they're like oh I want to be a princess
I never wanted to do that I always
wanted to be like something scary or
ugly
um just because that's how I roll so you
know I always wanted to be like a witch
or a mommy or some [ __ ] like that I was
a Jawa one year my mom made that costume
it was like pretty Epic but I never
wanted to be anything like super girly
girly because I always like really liked
scary [ __ ] I like scary [ __ ] so I always
wanted to be something scary so I think
that kind of like carried over
into adulthood yeah like it's okay if it
looks hot too like actually that's the
ideal I like the I like the very small
intersection of like scary and hot you
know what I mean yeah those girls there
was no scary to it that's what I mean
they were kind of like what you would
what the Japanese would call like a
kawaii version right that's what I'm
saying yeah I think that's what bothers
me more than anything like not so much
like the concept of it because I do like
the overlap of like of like hot and
scary you know what I mean so like if
you're gonna do
I don't know like I saw this one costume
that somebody had done online that was
like a Sea Hag you know what I mean or
like a scared like an evil mermaid and
it was like hot but it was also like
scary and like frightening and like
disturbing looking I'm like that's like
the ideal for me like Halloween costume
that kind of range you know like
monstery but also kind of sexy at the
same time yeah we're early because we
got to get the show done early before
the trick-or-treaters show up
yeah because we didn't want the doorbell
ranging like every five seconds and it's
better time to like run downstairs and
get the kids and I knew we'd be tired so
it's better to get this over with early
so we could hit the sack or [ __ ]
whatever earlier
too you know what I mean but like I said
it was it was harder because like as
soon as like like 1 30 came along I was
like oh [ __ ] I have to start like
putting all this [ __ ] makeup on and
stuff like that but like I said I was
glad to get it over with faster I was
glad that because I I was worried like I
said about this costume because I didn't
know how I was gonna look I imagined it
and then when I was getting ready on
Saturday I gave myself like five hours
on Saturday because I said hey if I
started doing the makeup and I [ __ ] it
up and then I have to wash it all off
and start over like I'm gonna need like
a lot of time so I gave myself like
pretty much all day
but I was doing I was doing it and then
I had it all put together I'm like
I was like oh my God it looks good and
then like I was then Tom came in and
he's like oh my God that looks awesome I
don't know it's like yes because that
was because he's like super critical I
thought he was gonna come in and go now
looks kind of dumb
[Laughter]
to me it looked like a silent film like
1920s yeah see that's what I kind of
like liked about it that it kind of had
that like vintage Hollywood kind of look
to it also it's kind of like the Medusa
costume the leading lady would show up
in while she's dancing for the audience
in the movie right like she's works at
the nightclub yeah it's like that yeah I
think that's what I liked about the vibe
yeah and honestly I was like really I
was surprised because I mean a lot of
people had really super cool costumes
when we went out Saturday night like a
lot of people had lame ones too but and
or no costume but a lot of people had
really really good ones and I got a lot
of like every time I walk through the
club I like to go to the bathroom or get
a drink or something like that people
like oh my God
and like some people were just kind of
like it's like hey can I take my picture
like people I even know like wanted to
take pictures of me that one like that
one couple that were um they were like
Day of the Dead and they went all out
too like she had like a big huge gown
and like the whole all the roses and
they did all the makeup her and her
boyfriend did and it looked amazing and
they came over and they were like can we
take a picture with you and I was like
okay they were like super cute I didn't
even know who they were yeah they were
like they seemed young I couldn't tell
because of the makeup but what's up okay
yeah I got a good reaction too that club
was crowded I was getting groped and
[ __ ] yeah he told me it's like it's like
all these drunk ladies are like groping
him yeah grabbing titties
who was that they were hot though
Jenny was [ __ ] right behind me in
[ __ ] one of them [ __ ] grew up man
I turned around and looked at her and I
said you see that she grabbed me [ __ ]
I didn't see it though yeah I was right
I was looking at something else or it's
kind of dark in there I was probably
like looking down at the floor and make
sure I didn't trip yeah or step on
anybody yeah I was coming going because
it was kind of like throwing out the
back three gay dudes came out [ __ ]
dressed like hamburgers and hot dogs and
[ __ ] and they went oh
you know when I had my bang mask on and
everything and everything was good the
the strongest reaction I got was like
from Latino dudes in their 20s whole
[ __ ] gang of them started Bang You're
[ __ ] Batman yeah they were yelling at us
so I gotta go back with Danny Trejo's
voice you know Batman
last time I saw you I broke your back
the next time I see you I will break
your soul I [ __ ] love it they just
like all cracked up
[Laughter]
but yeah it was yeah it was super fun
yeah I was thinking oh another good
costume I saw one girl uh who we kind of
know but she did a corpse bride and she
had her dress like lit up and everything
like the bottom of it was like all lit
up and she had like all the little
dreadlocks and all the makeup she had
all the body paint on and all that kind
of stuff that was one thing I didn't do
and I said this is one just for
practical reasons now initially what I
was gonna do
um is because see these are like fishnet
types but they have like a snake pattern
on them and I was like oh that's kind of
neat now initially though because I
didn't want to do body paint like oh
because this is just body paint
obviously but I didn't want to do body
paint like on my arms and [ __ ] because I
said well it's just gonna like rub off
yeah what's the guy supposed to be
the comic book version of Bane yeah he
just took I just got the mask he took
the mask off so he could drink so I can
drink yeah but um but yeah so I
initially had ordered a pair of green
tights and I was gonna make like a shirt
out of the like sleeves out of that and
then I was gonna put this over it so
it'd be like green underneath
um and then maybe like do some body
paint on the hands but the green shorts
the the green tights didn't like arrive
in time so I was just like well [ __ ] it
and then like I said when I was going
out I said I'm not putting body paint
like all over my [ __ ] arms because
it'll just rub off like especially like
underneath this so I said well I'll just
be a two-tone
because it's like that was one because I
was disappointed but you know what I
mean there was like one concession of
practicality I guess because I didn't
get I thought that the makeup that I
ordered because there's that makeup
that's like body paint but it's like
water activated and it's supposed to
like stay on better and the kind that I
got I thought was water activated but
it's not it was actually more it's not
grease paint it's not that squishy but
it's still like you still need powder to
set it
and it wasn't waterproof either so I was
like okay well there's no way I'm gonna
like put that all over my arms and have
that stay like all night everybody just
like rub it off so I didn't bother
let's see he's supposed to be Tom yeah
no hey and Tom are caught a crossover
there
Hugo says Jenny you look a bit like uh
Zeta Johan uh as the princess on the
mummy 1932. oh yeah okay I'll take it
I'll take it but yeah that's what it is
I really like this headpiece actually
I'm gonna keep this [ __ ]
but there's a lot of Medusa head pieces
but like 99 of them are [ __ ] looking
and I didn't really have the time or the
patience to make my own I saw this
really great like video
because I was looking for makeup
tutorial videos and this one woman made
this amazing [ __ ] headdress that was
but it was super big she had like all
these kind of like wood she said it was
light but
um it had like all these wood uh dowels
like making this kind of crown like
solar Crown kind of situation and then
like she had all these snakes kind of
going up like that and then she had like
a bunch of she just got like all of
these
um they were kind of like long pieces of
I guess they were just foam like black
foam like for some I guess she went on
my Home Depot or something and she just
kind of like looped them in the back
like to give it all this like volume it
was massive but she said it didn't like
weigh hardly anything and it looked
Kick-Ass but I was like oh my God that
would take [ __ ] forever and I just
don't have the time or the patience to
do that kind of stuff maybe if I have
more time but you know
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do let's see I put a guy in time out for
calling you a guy what I put I put
somebody in somebody instead of calling
you a guy who's that guy with the thing
on his head you know who's that guy with
it yeah she's calling you a guy yeah
uh okay
I don't know how many guys with [ __ ]
huge [ __ ] did but never mind well I
don't like I don't am I supposed to be
insulted
why would I be I don't [ __ ] know you
what the [ __ ] would I care
uh I don't know people are so funny they
actually think I give a [ __ ] with it
you think about me
all right what is this light popping up
that's like email and [ __ ] like that
let's see
um
blog Pro says I'm generic I always go as
Mario that's all that's all right though
that's all right though
Tom turned to hit a stone
yeah uh black Park said you two are
early on The Haunting review today yeah
we like I said we decided because it's
Halloween
we decided to do it early because we
didn't want the show to keep getting
interrupted by the doorbell ringing and
I was having to like run downstairs and
give kids candy because we do have I
don't think we had a [ __ ] ton last year
but we did have a significant amount of
trick-or-treaters like once it got dark
so we wanted it to be kind of like done
before it got dark and plus we figured
like other people would want to do stuff
like on Halloween too like maybe they're
going out or maybe they're taking their
kids trick-or-treating or something like
that yeah so and wouldn't want to like
it'd be done by the time you guys we did
the show will be done by the time you
guys got a trick or treat sure because
uh we're in [ __ ] East Time Zone
Eastern Standard Time yeah
that's what we're doing
but yeah so I'm gonna put the glasses on
again even though I don't I don't love
it but you know what I mean
I
mean
all right so this show here man cursed
The Mummy we wanted to do this one
because we've seen it before a couple of
times and I was like well it's kind of
Halloween themed because it's Mommy
um also it's ridiculous and we don't
know if these [ __ ] are trolling
I'm pretty sure these guys are trolled I
think they trolled The Haunting series
although I mean if they did like I
admire the dude for being able to keep a
straight face the whole time yeah and
this this case involves uh the legendary
Billy Bean okay he's on a bunch of these
[ __ ] he's he's kind of like he's
trying to take over the mantle from the
Warrens basically oh wait Louie said
Jenny what's your favorite horror movie
if you had to pick one oh
foreign
yes this is The Reptilian one this is
The Reptilian mummy [ __ ] AP or what
was it soap so bad so back that's right
yeah because there's another car hey
maybe that's what I'll be next year so
I'll get a big crocodile here right
so we're gonna we're gonna get off into
this one
I found something I didn't find like a
lot of uh exterior
um you know information about this one
but one thing I did find there was
um a YouTube video it was only like
three or four minutes long it was like
from the you know Paranormal Files of
Billy Bean or whatever and it had an
interview with this guy that was on here
his name is Caleb Weaver by the way
um and some of the stuff he said it's
not like a huge deal but some of the
stuff he said in there like kind of I
don't know if it contradicted like what
he said on a haunting but it's not
exactly the same and I'm not really sure
why they changed it
Jeffy Hart said I'm back in Medusa's cut
classes only Jenny can rock the Gorgon
intellectual look yeah I was like not a
smart Medusa well like I said it's like
I it's kind of making me mad that like I
have to wear them but I really I can't
see my notes like I can't see any of the
comments or anything like that
everything just looks like super blurry
so I had to like put the glasses on
yeah Louie said good choice Jenny yeah I
mean that's really I mean the thing
would be in there too and like if you
ask me at a different day that might
also be like my number one but
I feel like The Shining just because I
never get tired of watching it you know
I mean like I've watched it like over
and over and I always find something
different in it all the time
so maybe that's why
but yeah so
so this show it was from well this was
season seven as we've said like after
season four or five it started going
downhill
Oh Thomas and glorious bastard said
what's up Tom you're going as Bronson to
the Halloween party no man look I don't
have my mask on this is this is stuck in
um The Comic version of Bane
about my mask right here but I can't
[ __ ] wear the mask and drink at the
same time well you can put it on just
for like this every now and then maybe
I'll put the drink on for the sake of
new people that are around new
[ __ ]
yeah because that's that's the thing
like I said that's why I have to keep
putting my glasses on and taking my
glasses off because the costume looks
better without the glasses but I can't
see without the glasses so
[Laughter]
there you go see there you go there you
go y'all be happy now y'all be happy now
yeah
[Music]
I look better with the mask my [ __ ]
covering up my ugly ass [ __ ] face
well no it's just it's well you look
better with the mask because it all
looks it goes together like you actually
look like it looks like a Halloween I'm
missing one piece though it's got a
spike collar but I forgot to put it on
oh that's right yeah you had that on
Saturday yeah because he wears a spike
collar like a dog collar
yeah well you didn't realize what time
it was I just came I was yeah I was
looking ahead hurry up yeah I just gave
it like four minutes before I'm like uh
are you are you ready or and he was like
oh yeah well I had it I'm gonna close on
yeah you had your clothes on you just
didn't have you just forget to have a
little jewelry stuff yeah well you know
that's how that's how [ __ ] happens
that's how [ __ ] happens let me see if I
put this back on
October says if you don't wear your
glasses you'll get a headache at least I
do if I don't have mine on
yeah I mean
uh into green70 it said honestly your
makeup looks so good that the glasses
don't take away from your look at all
thank you very much thank you I
appreciate that
um I figured if I know where the contact
lens is though it's like well I have to
at least like have people see those
because they're a pain in the ass and
you know you can't really see them with
the glasses on but I do have contact
lenses on too like green reptilian ones
um
I like that though that's good that's
kind of cute honestly you can't really
see you Batman
I don't think because I'm blind I can't
see you I was born in the darkness you
owned you merely adopted it
it's not so bad though because you can't
actually see them all that much you know
what I mean because only you can see
like that little part of the frame but
you can't like see the glasses all that
much
October says uh Tom put a hole in the
mask against straw yeah
they got several different masks you can
get because it was drawn a lot of
different ways
I'll probably get a couple more in this
style
some of them do have a mask some of them
are straight of a Mexican Luchador mask
that has a square there and it's for his
eyes too
so you could there's different versions
of this he wore a bunch of different
[ __ ] and he's drawn differently and a
bunch of stuff but the next costume I'm
gonna get is the Tom Hardy one with the
[ __ ] face mask and the [ __ ] body
armor I have a lot of that already yeah
so I'll do that one
and then I'll just learn that voice so
I can't do his voice I can do that voice
but I gotta I gotta get I gotta practice
for it yeah he's gotta be drunk to be
dude yeah
and you thought you were in charge
you gotta see how to
uh no I'd have to [ __ ] be alone for a
while and [ __ ] practice that one
I used to be alone yeah because uh
you don't wanna you wanna put your best
foot forward first you know
I could do the exact same one [ __ ]
hard he's done it I've done it before
it's just I did it without thinking
about it when you think about it it
actually it trips yeah just [ __ ] do
it yeah
yeah
uh Tay says light cabinet of curiosity
is you asking if I like cabin of cure I
like I really like it so far I've only
gotten up to
um I think I only saw like the first
four episodes last night I watched
pikmin's model like the one with it's
with uh Crispin Glover the ones based on
the HP Lovecraft story and uh I really
like that a lot actually pikmin's model
is one of my favorite Lovecraft stories
so I thought it was cool that they
adapted it
but that's if that's the fourth one then
that's the one and then because I
watched two last night I watched that
one and the one before it which was the
one about the weird skin cream that made
the that was uh Anna Lily uh ammonbor
like she directed it that was good too
but yeah I've been watching it I like it
so far like I said maybe maybe the
pigments model was the fifth one
now I can't remember
but I've been watching it slowly I think
I'm gonna do
um later on in November probably like
mid-november I was planning on doing
like a video over on scare Salon of like
the whole like reviewing the whole
series so I'm kind of like watching them
absolutely like one or two every now and
then what are you doing Pokey
she's tearing up the books again
uh Tay said yes I really love it I
figured you guys would like it reminds
me of Twilight Zone yeah and it's
honestly
um it seems like as much as I like Creep
Show um the new one like on shutter like
I think this is a little bit better it
seems like it has like higher production
values you know what I mean and I don't
know the stories they chose are better I
liked that they chose graveyard rats too
because I really like that story a lot I
mean it's been adapted a bunch of times
but
um but I think they did a good job on
that
but uh yeah so
uh Thompson Gloria's bastard said for a
moment I thought it was the Dagon Queen
yeah that's I've been one that's my like
ideal costume but I haven't been able to
get that one together so I gotta have a
whole wheelchair that's what I mean I
need a wheelchair and tentacles and yeah
you know I'd have to like look at what
she's doing the only thing I'm not a fan
of with that costume is that you
wouldn't get to do like any cool makeup
on your face because her face just looks
kind of like regular yeah like she
doesn't look monstrous or anything so
that's the only thing that's kind of
well it's not the only thing though the
thing is I can't afford a wheelchair but
um I kind of prefer ones where you can
do like some scary makeup you know what
I mean and you can't really do that with
her because she I don't think it'd be a
good costume it'd be very impractical
she looks kind of regular yeah that's
the thing that would be something if you
were just kind of like not going
anywhere not going anyplace
if you're expanding it if you were just
doing like a photo shoot or something
like that you know what I mean
but yeah it's not
Danny Rowling said didn't Medusa give
birth to a Minotaur
wait did she yeah yeah maybe I think
maybe yeah maybe I think some of the
blood from her severed head caused a
Minotaur or something or something
something like that well her blood was
acid right yeah but I thought it or some
[ __ ] like I thought some of the blood
from her severed head ended up making
monsters
uh I don't know now I can't remember
you know I'm just all I'm remembering is
like [ __ ] from Clash of the Titans what
would be good for you Jenny is to do a
werewolf version of you
a werewolf version of me yeah that might
be really cool
you think I should do a werewolf yeah
sexy werewolf yeah I can do that that
may be kind of fun oh that's Thomas
fetish I guess yeah
yeah like almost almost kind of like
across the tree and like the howling and
the sugar
snaps something like that like an
in-between version of that where you're
wearing clothes but you have fur too and
you have kind of [ __ ] like a little
bit of a dog face and but you know boobs
in the whole nine yards
can I have more than two boobs yeah and
then yeah I could do that maybe well if
you well how would that look in human
clothes but you'd definitely have to
have a tail it'd almost be kind of like
a furry costume maybe but not cheesy not
cheap like I'd wanna like I said oh if
I'm gonna be aware of if I'm gonna be a
scary werewolf yeah yeah you know I like
I want to be scary it should be hot
though too well that's what I mean hot
scary yeah that's like the ideal
combination yeah hot and scary yeah I
don't like costumes that are just hot
I kind of like ones that are just scary
I like the clothes from from the sugar
snaps Ginger Snaps girl uh movie yeah
clothes like that
but if the face is a little bit more
like the howling
you know what I mean or maybe dog
soldiers yeah something like that yeah
something like dog soldiers but with
human body mostly but with you know
furry maybe arms and legs and a furry
back I thought about doing I thought
about being a wendigo but I thought that
would be like too much trouble
because that would entail like a whole
like [ __ ] antler headpiece and yeah
[ __ ] like that but that was one of the
things I was considering and I don't
think a a whole head mask just as maybe
a snout
with a bunch of fern yeah I mean I would
want to do like you want it to look cool
but I wouldn't necessarily just want to
wear a mask because then you'd have to
like take it off so I'd have to do like
latex and then you and and you don't
want it to be so extreme you couldn't
drink or eat or uh talk you know you
want to be able to do stuff in it so it
yeah that's a real light latex work
maybe yeah
kind of like yeah like a dog dog you
know fangs dog fangs and stuff
I might consider that next year actually
good contact really cool wig
[ __ ] brown or black or probably you
know and with your pointed ears dog
years definitely any point in here and
uh yeah and uh
not hair everywhere but just you know
hair in certain areas well yeah because
that would be hot as [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
might as well be one of the costume
characters at Disney you'd be like in
there sweating your balls a big wig
would be good enough and a tail yeah I
mean as long as you could kind of like
you could paint fur in certain areas on
you or what you could do is you could
get like um I'm sure they sell like
probably just like you could get like a
shirt there was like nylon that had like
fur over it and then like because this
situation like this kind of situation
but like with fur or you could even get
a pair of nylons and just like glue fur
to it you could do that too and then
just like wear it like you know what I
mean yeah
uh Hugo said Jenny I've been watching
your book versus movie episodes on scare
Salon pretty good thank you I've been
like uh I'll probably do another one of
those in November but I haven't decided
which one I'm gonna do yet so it needs
to be something that is a book I've read
before that I'm real familiar with in a
movie that I'm real familiar with so you
know so when I reread it and re-watch it
it's not like coming out of the [ __ ]
coming out of nowhere
the boobinator I mean I do I like the
idea honestly I kind of like the idea of
if you're being a werewolf I kind of
like the naked werewolf thing you know
what I mean like more like um you're
wearing a bodysuit yeah yeah yeah and
like I said I like the idea of having
like several titties like that appeals
to me yeah and because I like the dog
Soldier werewolves that are just like
kind of this or the howling werewolves
that are like uh on their back legs
would be a lot more expensive to do that
it would yeah but I'm just saying I like
that look more than
werewolves wearing clothes it would be
better with the old school werewolf with
clothes a lot cheaper a lot more
practical especially for Club use
I know you could just do it less clothes
that's true you know what I'm talking
about like a body stocking with a little
bit of clothes over it
that's what I was thinking like you
could wear something it was almost like
the Hulk like you turned into this when
you still had clothes like oh [ __ ] it's
that time of the month or whatever and
then like the clothes just yeah
something like that
that's kind of more what I was thinking
because if not you'd have fur everywhere
to burn you up yeah
and then go into the bathroom in that
well see that's another thing and it's
like that's that's why actually this
costume was so nice because it didn't
have it didn't involve a lot of stuff
like going on because it's just like a
toga and then I just had tights on
underneath so it was like easy to go to
the bathroom if I had to yeah um you
know I didn't have like 40 bajillion
things because some of the people in
there like some of the costumes they
were wearing like oh my God how are you
gonna pay you want to be able to dance
at it too or you just yeah you just
can't and you talk about Florida okay
yeah so there's limitations
and I think scantily clad werewolf would
be the best
like a skirt then he's you're wearing a
body suit but you got a little skirt on
it
and a little some kind of little top or
a vest of some sort I bet it's like you
transformed yeah and then that's what
I'm saying like like I said it could
even be like torn up it right yeah but
in general it's a skirt with a I like
the idea too of having like shoes that
kind of look like like feet kinda or
like or at least fur boots or something
like that might work also yeah because
they do have like boots you could just
imagine or something or you could even
like buy a pair of like generic boots
and like glue for um yeah like that
would be cheap yeah you could do that
too put little nails on them
going down the [ __ ] uh platform you
know
like you'd see on kiss now kids got
fakes and [ __ ] going down yeah they have
nails that [ __ ] go down like you're
like their [ __ ] toenails and uh what
you do is you get like a set of the
stripper shoes that have the [ __ ]
clear heel on the back
yeah so there's but then you put fur
everywhere else you're not really
supposed to see the clear here right
Just an Illusion so it looks like you're
walking on your tiptoes
yeah see I like that I like that yeah
because they would walk on their Lane
and they probably sell [ __ ] like that
anyway well they do and like I said
nowadays because everybody without
[ __ ] heels in the back sometimes I
mean because everyone is so into like
cosplay and you know there's furries and
stuff like that so you can get a lot
more [ __ ] yeah do you remember like one
we were kids and I was just watching
like a video about Halloween Nostalgia
the other day do you remember when we
were kids like the kind of Pinnacle of
the costumes was you'd buy it like in
this little you know bag or whatever and
it came with like that little plastic
mask and then it came with like a
plastic Smock that had
that had the like whole costume again on
it like for example like my brother was
the mummy one year like the classic like
Boris Carl the Boris Karloff Mommy
the universal one and it came with like
a mummy mask which was just plastic and
was just like had a little [ __ ] uh
you know drawstring on it or whatever
the mask was okay like it looked all
right and then it comes with like a
yellow smile I think they were all
yellow if I could remember correctly or
black and it came with like a yellow
Smock and then like on the front it had
like the mummy on it it said the mummy
in case you didn't know like from
looking at the mask and I had one like
that too but it was kind of like it was
like a witch
I just see I don't think they called it
a witch though I think they called it
like a sorceress or something but like
the face was kind of green and she had
like this she had actual real like hair
coming out the side but then like it
just came with like a yellow Smock that
said
Phantom or sorceress or whatever the
[ __ ] the name is I don't remember what
it was called I have a picture of me
somewhere like wearing that because I
was probably like six or some [ __ ] like
that or yeah six or seven
but it's just it's so much better like
the [ __ ] you can get nowadays like I
said I
I easily found uh you know snake contact
lenses I found like a [ __ ] uh stencil
that was like reptilian skin that was
exactly for this kind of thing like if
you wanted to make yourself look like a
snake or whatever so and it was like two
bucks
so I work up a good [ __ ] werewolf I
mean that's a good idea I don't think
I've ever done a werewolf my brother did
a werewolf in here but I think it was
just kind of like your classic it's
weird because whenever you like buy like
especially if you see like dudes
werewolf costumes they always are
wearing like a checkered like a plaid
shirt and jeans but they're always kind
of like raggedy at the end and I'm like
why that's specifically you could go in
there like a [ __ ] bombshell yeah I
like that but I like that idea actually
that's one of the better ideas that
you've had yeah like in a bra
with [ __ ] tatters of a [ __ ] top on
some kind of short skirt
or something like a short skirt so maybe
torn up
with a [ __ ] tail
exposed legs
but like I said you got a bodysuit you
were talking about yeah and a [ __ ]
sexy [ __ ] foot shoes
it would look good
yeah I think it would you look good I
think it would if I could get this in
those gloves that have extended fingers
to make your fingers longer yeah yeah I
like that idea too yeah big [ __ ] wig
pointed ears [ __ ] would put some
latex snout on you teeth
contacts [ __ ] cool eyebrows
and spray your face or do your face in a
different color like brown or whatever
color the hair is so it just Blends in
you know to change your hairline so just
see how other people did it
yeah like I said you can I mean you can
find all kind of yeah makeup tutorials
that's where it's like you know I did I
found you can put your bra get your
[ __ ] badass bra put that over the
bodysuit so the bodysuit is kind of like
supposed to be the fur or something yeah
you know what I mean it would look good
yeah I actually kind of like that idea
now that I'm thinking about it like
because like I said I don't think I've
ever done a werewolf did work yeah
but that's the that seems good because
like I said it's still it's scary and
it's monstery and I like that it would
be hot yeah see that's like the perfect
combination yeah it's the perfect
combination
and it's not really an ugly
costume either yeah you know you can
make a you can make a female werewolf
look really good
just like you can make a dab female
vampire look good you can make a female
werewolf look good too yeah yeah and you
don't see I don't see any werewolves
yeah
I kind of feel like you see werewolves
but the ones that I've seen it's usually
that's a dude costume but even like they
they do have like a sexy werewolf one
that you can buy but it's not it's not
cool no you didn't make dumb looking
yeah that's that's what I mean you would
definitely have to make it maybe put you
in the snout to be almost kind of like
something out of the old school Planet
of the Apes
yeah yeah yeah it's like a snack because
they could still talk and they could
still talk and they could you could
drink you could just drink with a straw
to be honest I think you can buy like
latex appliances like that that are
already made and you can just like
put it on like that and then you paint
it over
one year and this was like a while back
and I don't think they make these
anymore
but one year I bought this great
it was like it was a mask but it was
kind of like it was a molded mask but
you could kind of like it but it was a
whole thing it wasn't just like a bunch
of like latex appliances and you like
glued it to your face like you cut it to
fit your face pretty much and then like
you just glued it on there and then you
painted it like however you wanted it
and I got the witch one one year
and it looked great it looked like and
it was cheap it was only like a couple
bucks or something like obviously I had
to paint it and it took a while like it
came with the mask and then it came with
paints
so I painted it before I put it like I
cut it and like you know fit it on my
face but when I put it on my face it
looked like my actual face
and that was a great year because it's
like and then I just got like the hat
and like I had a raggedy old like black
dress and everything and then I sat on
my porch with a bowl of candy and no
kids would come up to the porch because
I just sat there and rocked like that
and I had like the face like looked so
horrifying that they were like they
would come by and they'd be like nope
that they like can't fall right it was
like it was so funny that was when I
have a picture of it somewhere but that
was like a long time ago I think it was
like a teenager but I don't know if they
make those anywhere I've never seen them
anywhere I don't remember what company
it was or anything but it was cheap and
they came out like really really good
let's see
um
Jeff heard said I thought the news
ladies transformation of the howling was
a very good werewolf makeup job yeah I
mean the howling the makeup is really
really good howling one was good how two
[ __ ] sucked and all the other socket
from what I remembered but howling one
was [ __ ] a masterpiece yeah it was
really good and like I said I know that
um you know obviously American Werewolf
in London like that it's hard to beat
that makeup but the howling was like
really really good too and I really
liked the werewolves in that like I said
yeah they kind of reminded me of more of
like dog soldiers because like I really
liked well the werewolves and dog
soldiers it that was actually like
either really tall dudes or dudes on
like slight stilts
and then they have like the whole body
suit so they would look like much taller
and they had like you said like those
big long fingers like with the claws and
stuff it was like really really cool
looking yeah you couldn't do that here
in Florida because those suits were all
fur you'd burn well yeah I would
probably have a stroke yeah
could you wear that in a [ __ ] club
you'd be dead [ __ ] 10 minutes later
yeah dehydration
like I said I don't know it has to be
just I don't know how those Disney
costume characters do it uh like a uh it
has to be kind of like a leotard type
bodysuit yeah to simulate that for might
have some fur in it and then you'd put
clothes over that and you then you need
a mask for it with a wig that wig alone
would [ __ ] it [ __ ] you up here in
Florida
because you just can't release enough
heat through your head
women suffer with them damn wigs we do
yeah yeah well and the thing and here's
another thing you're not considering too
is that underneath the wig you also cut
I have a wig cap because I have hair so
I have to put like you can get ones I
have nylon ones and fishnet ones but you
have to like put a model and like tuck
all your hair up into it so it doesn't
like peek out like she has hair I don't
I can throw a wig yeah like it's easier
for you but yeah I have to like put it
on and like then tuck all my hair up
underneath it like and flatten it out
and then put the wig on but I go to the
food clubs like coat it if I want to and
it would still be [ __ ] hot even with
a bald head yeah it'll be hot
I thought about it says now to be
[ __ ] just to wear that [ __ ] as a gag
I'd be [ __ ] burning up all night
[ __ ] now I can wear that
[ __ ] everybody knows I still think he
should I still think you should do uh
Coney and the Barbarian one here if I go
[ __ ] dress up like that I'm [ __ ]
dressed up I'm not quite big enough to
pull out Conan yeah you could you could
totally pull off code I could pull off
I'd be much better as just a gladiator a
generic [ __ ] glass or something
mermillo costume or a [ __ ] secutor
you know so they have really nice
gladiator costumes actually
but you know
let's see what time is it it's 5 11. see
do you want to actually talk about this
episode or does anyone care it's time to
pull the church let's pull the trigger
on it we can Coast through it if you got
if we want to if it's fast it's fast or
not we'll just shoot the [ __ ] well and I
did like title it you know curse the
mummy and spooky Side Tracks yeah so
it's all right we're not good because
like I said I'm like you know we could
talk about that but we can talk about
other [ __ ] too because it's the
Halloween special so I didn't like
necessarily just want to like limit it
to just talking about haunting but we
did watch this episode and it's kind of
Halloween based because it's about a
bummy yeah although okay here's what I'm
gonna say spoiler alert I found I think
I mentioned this a long time ago I found
a YouTube video that had an interview
with this guy I think it was from
2000
or 2020 or no 2020.
um and he said basically the same [ __ ]
that he said about that he was haunted
by the crocodile demon or whatever but
he didn't mention that
um that he had started being haunted
after seeing a mummy at a museum and he
actually implied that the haunting had
started much earlier than the show did
and I'm not entirely sure like why that
whole [ __ ] was changed you know what I'm
saying we're handing out kitkats and
[ __ ] Reese's Peanut Butter Cups
mostly yeah yeah hopefully we don't get
too many like people because then I can
like have
you didn't even tell me like my wig was
sliding off I didn't notice I couldn't
really see it
that's a good wig you should wear that
for other things yeah that's what I
figured it was just like I said it's not
necessarily a Medusa egg it's called
it's called Zombie rocker it looks cool
it's just dreadlocks that would work
just for a goth outfit yeah
this thing's kind of crazy
I might have to knock you down on that
wig one of these days you're weird
though I don't know I gotta do that guys
I can't help it oh and I wanted to show
too like I don't know if you can see
like because like I said it's a lot of
things that No One's Gonna notice but
this necklace that I got is all it's
like a whole bunch of little overlapping
cobras
and I don't know if anybody noticed that
or not but you know Danny got a good
idea if you could recycle that wig as a
female predator you as a female oh no
but I've never seen that
now that's a good okay I gotta get a
mask for that I'm writing that but the
rest of that would be a pretty easy I'm
writing down werewolf and female maybe I
can do two costumes people yeah two
things werewolf and Predator yeah ooh I
like that
that's a great idea actually I like the
world fight yeah I like the Predator
idea because yeah I could use this wig
again for that
foreign
yeah Danny really said Jenny with a
shoulder Cannon missile would look sick
oh my God if I get one it's like a laser
it like lit up and stuff that had like
the little three dots on it oh my God
I'm gonna do that now
like I said I could do two costumes at
midnight
that [ __ ] anavar [ __ ] running on a
damn [ __ ] bicycle over there [ __ ]
get you looking like the predator
good work
yeah get you climbing trees
well let's not get excited yeah
um but yeah all right so or do you want
to talk about this now yeah go ahead
okay
I wonder like I said it's Halloween show
we're talking about [ __ ] talking
about [ __ ] mummies and [ __ ]
so uh so yeah so this story here like I
said this was season seven episode 14 I
think it was
and it took place in uh Upstate New York
so there's like a small town called I
think it was called Geneva because I was
like oh like in Switzerland yeah Geneva
like but Upstate New York
um and according to the narrator
uh the kind of place where families live
in the same house for Generations or at
least this family in particular did
here's one thing like when we were
starting to watch this episode I said I
wonder if Anthony call who's the guy
that narrates these I wonder if like he
got the script for this one and he's
like are you [ __ ] kidding me with
this like and I still have to like make
this sound scary
but he's I mean he's a PR he's a trooper
he's been doing it a long time and he's
a professional I'm sure but because if
it was me I'd have been like oh come on
now it's a paycheck
and I guess that's like what he's known
for well he doesn't only just do a
haunting because he does like some true
crime shows too
like his you know it's he's got that
great [ __ ] voice and it's weird
because this always happens whenever I'm
so used to like hearing somebody's voice
like doing voiceovers on and then I see
a picture of them they never look the
way I'm expecting them and I'm not
really sure like what I'm expecting them
to look like what does he look like
um
yeah yeah it's just first I don't know
what I'm expecting is is what I'm trying
to say like I'm not really sure what I
expected you give me anything he'll read
it he sounds like that yeah and he
sounds like really authoritative and
like everything sounds like super creepy
yeah even stuff even stuff like this
I think I think they're trolling I
suspect that but like I said I I admire
their commitment to the troll yeah if
that's what it is uh so yeah so like I
said the dude at the center of this is a
guy named Caleb uh Weaver and he's
actually on the show although they
talked to his mom although his mom
insisted on being like in Shadow yeah
they said because of her uh career
because of her job or whatever okay but
yeah all right um so so I don't know but
um but his wife was on there and his
friend was on there and Bill Bean was on
there yeah but his mom I was like well
if if Caleb Weaver is using his real
name it's like everybody's gonna know
who his [ __ ] mom is so it's like not
really I don't really see the point of
it deniability I guess she's like that
wasn't me that's like some other my son
is playing himself
I guess
so yeah so he said he grew up in this uh
Town Geneva in uh Geneva and Upstate New
York and they lived in
um you know like I said this house had
been in their uh in their family for
Generations it was his mom's mom's house
and so that's where they were living so
now when this story starts Caleb is 14.
so he's lived with the parents who
they're calling Chris and Susan I'm
assuming that's not their real names and
at first he's like oh you know I had a
pretty typical childhood everything you
know it was a nice place to grow up he
could ride your bikes everywhere and
you'd play baseball and do all that kind
of like [ __ ] stereotypical [ __ ] or
whatever
um so it's kind of like uh and also he
kind of was I don't know he just seemed
like a very typical student they said he
was you know In The Swim Club he played
trombone in the band he was just like
did normal [ __ ]
now at the beginning they had this scene
where uh you know he comes out to eat
breakfast and his dad's like uh hey
don't you have a field trip at school
today and you know okay like fake Caleb
the kid is just kind of like yeah but it
sounds boring and then his dad's like
yeah but boring or not you gotta go and
at this point what okay and I was saying
this to Tom I was like why does this
always happen in movies this happens a
lot of movies and TV shows like they'll
have a scene where like the kid will
come downstairs for breakfast and then
Mom or Dad or whoever is like making
breakfast and like but come down it's
breakfast time or whatever and they like
make this big full breakfast right like
eggs and bacon and [ __ ] like that which
on a weekday okay but um so they make
that and then they give it to the kid
and then the kid hasn't even eaten
anything yet and then they're like you
better go you'll be late the bus is
coming I'm like well that's on you you
should have started making breakfast
earlier yeah let's make that kid late
yeah
because that well because that happened
in this world like he hasn't even eaten
anything he just sat down and they're
like well you're gonna be late and I'm
like okay why did you even bother
getting a breakfast then just throw my
granola bar like get out the door or a
Pop Tart or something but it's like
nobody like eggs and bacon and hash
browns and pancakes and like the [ __ ]
the whole like Denny's Grand Slam and
then say that the [ __ ] then say he's
gonna miss the bus I'm like what the
[ __ ] did you think was gonna happen
but yeah so he says uh yeah the trip
sounds boring and blah blah
and so um
all right so this is apparently I guess
he was 14 like back in Spring of 1997.
so they go to the museum and uh one of
the I don't know what kind of Museum it
was but um they're like one of the
things was they had got the museum had
just got like all of these uh ancient
Egyptian artifacts you know dating back
to 2000 BC
so Caleb said as soon as he got in there
he said he felt like super drawn to the
Egyptian exhibit and the artifacts
um he said everything else seemed to
tune itself out uh as I'm looking at
everything I felt kind of separated from
everyone so he's going into like a zone
or whatever while he's like looking at
all the Egyptian stuff
and um then like the lady that's showing
them around the place
is like you know here's uh this mummy
this is like kind of the centerpiece of
the whole uh you know exhibit and it's
this mummy of uh you know kind of like a
priestess that supposedly served like
some Egyptian deity or something
um now according to the narrator it says
the Priestess supposedly worshiped a
volatile and aggressive God and the
deity may still be protecting her in the
afterlife that's what he said I'm like
yeah maybe maybe
but
[Laughter]
right yeah yeah he's going Old Testament
on it
you're gonna you're in you're in the era
where there's only one God but don't
worship any of them other ones okay
worshiping them other ones to get you a
lot of trouble
you know and Yahweh chose Israel his
brother brothers chose other tribes you
know don't be [ __ ] giving your kids
over to Molech all right [ __ ] give
your kids to Yahweh the firstborn okay
they've always tried to they've always
tried to rewrite that damn [ __ ]
Genesis but no it's all right there man
it's the father of the Gods
his wife who was the serpent you know
talking about they're talking about
Ashura okay she got demoted was had made
to crawl on her belly
to turn him to say that you know no yeah
and then uh all of God's Sons so you're
talking about Zeus Hera
all his other [ __ ] sons on Mount
Olympus and then
all the women they knock up and all the
children from them the demigods you know
like Perseus and all that well
in uh the uh the the [ __ ] Old
Testament you're talking about
uh Nephilim you know
[ __ ] Samson [ __ ] Goliath
those guys you know Giants men of great
renown
well the Egyptians were like that too A
lot of the [ __ ] got borrowed from the
Egyptians so they're talking about the
same [ __ ]
yeah that's what I mean it's I mean it
seems it stands to reason not because
Christianity came along later that they
were gonna like just incorporate because
it wasn't just kind of like hey we came
along and we're the right religion now
it was like a slow it was an evolution
process like an evolution they're gonna
borrow [ __ ] from like other older yeah
when you come up with a religion it's
not new
you're taking what's already in the
traditions and everything and rebooting
it
not really new it's a new spin you know
if I can
Jesus you know and Mary you know Jesus
the baby Jesus and Mary and God in
heaven that's [ __ ] Isis and Osiris
and the baby Horus you know Horus and
Osiris that's the Risen little baby
horse yeah the Arizona Cyrus and [ __ ]
Moon you know the [ __ ] father the sun
disc and Amun got Isis pregnant and made
little little horse
oh but no not horse but Osiris then you
became horse yeah
so cute yeah went up to heaven
but yeah that's like Jesus that's kind
of like the whole yeah see the Egyptian
gods like I said you know most of the
old religions were uh Manny Nicole said
Jenny you look gorgeous thank you I'll
do it without the glasses it looks
better without the glasses see because
then you can see the
contact lenses I don't know if like I
can't see if the um the things like turn
to the side
because they're supposed to be straight
up and down but they keep they keep like
rotating like in my eyeballs and I can't
keep I can't get it
but uh yeah let's see
Jeff here said I was raised Catholic but
I was always intrigued on how
Catholicism has a lot of commonalities
with paganism yeah and like I said
it's a reason because you know it's a
Roman religion sure and the Romans
borrowed everything that they knew from
the outside world at the end it was a
Roman reboot of a judaic religion it's
it's it's it's it's Judaism being
rebooted as a Roman religion and
Christianity wasn't the only one yeah I
mean nothing happens in a vacuum right
myths aren't created in a vacuum yeah
you know they're always gonna like
borrow from [ __ ] that came before yeah
so uh so yeah so and same with the
Egyptians they had all of these gods for
various things uh and especially this
God which is supposedly protecting this
mummy from incursions by priests or high
schoolers I guess
um because he's gonna like [ __ ] around
so uh so yeah so Caleb says that uh
seeing the mummy which I'm not sure what
the real one looked like but the one
that they showed on the show was
actually pretty cool it looked like a
real mummy I'm sure it probably wasn't
but they did a good job like whoever did
the special effect on it and they said
that like he said that the mummy was
like all wrapped on the bottom but then
they had like the face unwrapped so you
could look at it and he said that it was
uh really intense looking you could see
the whole face and he said it looked
like something out of a horror movie now
um he said that while he was standing
there looking at this mummy
uh he said he felt like he was kind of
Trapped in his own little world
um he said he wasn't really sure if
anybody else that was in there because
his other classmates were in there uh
were sure of what was going on but he
was just like sitting there staring at
it and it got like super super intense
and then he said as soon as they went
out of the gallery it was just like
relief and he was like really glad to
get out of there
was home and like tells his parents
because his dad's like hey how was that
boring ass Museum or whatever and he's
like um
he's like as soon as he got home he's
like well uh there was this mummy there
and it's like I was really unsettled by
it like she still had skin on her face
and
um I felt like she was like looking
right through me and I couldn't breathe
and like all this other kind of stuff so
I was like that's a weird thing to tell
your parents but okay so uh apparently
he did tell his parents all about that
now uh his mom his real mom was on there
in Shadow and she said that yeah after
he came home after seeing the mummy like
exhibit that he was like really scared
and
she said and this is like a direct quote
from the show she says we attributed it
to the fact that Caleb from a very young
age always had a very deep interest in
different topics when he got his mind
onto something it was very hard to get
him to think about anything else so when
he first started talking about the
museum we kind of said to ourselves well
this is Caleb's new obsession so they
thought that oh well it's mummies now
and that's just all he's gonna like
think or talk about for the next however
long so we're just gonna have to put up
with it
um and here's like funny too like fake
dad because whenever because his real
dad wasn't on the show so you know
reenactment dad was on there and he says
oh you're probably just a little freaked
out you saw a real mummy for the first
time that could be a little scary and
then I thought that was so funny like
the way he phrased it I was like because
his dad was like I remember the my first
time seeing real mummy you know what I
mean I was like what a weird thing to
say but uh but yeah it's like it's it's
a big part of everyone's life of a young
man's life when they first see their
their first mummy but uh but yeah so I
don't know why that [ __ ] I don't know
why that turned a phrase like made me
laugh so hard but it's it uh so
basically they're like uh so they didn't
really think anything weird was going on
they just said oh well you know you saw
Mommy and it upset you like it's a dead
person so it's not that strange I guess
um you know so they try to kind of like
rationalize it away I guess
and uh but Caleb says that he definitely
got the feeling that
um of like unease like in the house and
that he felt like he said I felt like I
was In Harm's Way that's what he said
so that night apparently after coming
home from the museum that he goes to bed
or whatever and he said that in his
bedroom he felt like someone was looking
at him and again like he couldn't really
breathe and then he said that he saw
glowing green eyes like in the corner of
the room and heard this growling sound
and he said that he was like scared as
you would be and then he heard like
heavy footsteps
um of this essentially a monster is what
it is like walking across the bedroom
and apparently I don't know how long it
was in there but he said like the next
day it was gone but apparently he said
that he saw this thing in his room like
it had glowing green eyes and like heavy
footsteps and blah blah
so they kind of imply first that maybe
this was nightmares but he's like I know
it wasn't nightmares like I know what
was you know what's real and what's not
and then there's a scene where the fake
mom says like the mom in the reenactment
is like
this was something else that made me
laugh because I'm a child but um she
said what was going on in your room last
night like all that Ruckus
and then immediately I was like you
heard my ruckus mom but um yeah
so apparently uh fate Caleb like the
Caleb in the um Brian agma is like wait
you heard it you heard the growling you
know what I mean like of this monster
into the room I don't know why I thought
that was funny but uh but yeah I don't
know this whole this whole episode kind
of cracked me up to be honest with you
so um so yeah so apparently she heard
some [ __ ] that was going on I don't know
they didn't specify she heard the
growling but she said she heard some
kind of ruckus like in the room I don't
know what that necessarily means but uh
but yeah so the mom is like she's like
yeah like right after he went to see
this mummy exhibit at the Museum that's
when he started started saying that he
heard things in his room like footsteps
and stuff and she said that he could
hear
um what sounded like somebody breathing
like in his room
and then um Caleb the real Caleb said uh
that it seemed or sounded like some kind
of like monster or animal or something
like that
um and he said I don't really know what
it was at first but like it definitely
wanted to hurt me that's what he said
um let's see okay so where was I all
right
um
yeah and so oh thanks like his dad says
you know you're too old to be seeing the
Boogeyman in your room you're 14
whatever it's just nightmares blah blah
uh and then the real mom comes on and
this is kind of like
um into grade 70 it's too much Ruckus
gives you hairy Palms that's kind of but
that's kind of where my brain was going
to that's why I laughed at like the way
he said you heard that you heard my
ruckus he didn't say that but that's
what I thought he's like he's he said uh
you heard that he's like you heard the
growling like there and there was like a
pause but I don't know you heard my
ruckus
um but yeah
so real mom in the show said
um I thought this was funny too like
everything about this is comedy gold but
um real mom says Caleb's always been a
very unique individual
I'm like one that's true of everybody
and two that sounds like she's trying to
be diplomatic and like saying that he's
a weirdo but not wanting to say that you
know what I mean like I'm not saying he
is a weirdo I don't know the dude but
I'm just saying that's kind of what like
it sounds like the mom is trying to get
at like but without saying that
um she says he seems to experience
emotions very strongly we just assume
that if we were patient and let him work
his way through it that would be the end
of it so you know maybe uh so like I
said Caleb just he's insistent that this
is not a nightmare that there's actually
like a monster in his room and he after
a while he's like well because his
parents were just kind of like blowing
him off and saying oh it's just a house
settling you're just having nightmares
or whatever you're too old for this [ __ ]
um he just like stopped telling them
what he what was going on and like
stopped telling his friends he said well
he thought nobody would believe him so
which is probably true because I because
I didn't believe him now uh so a couple
of weeks after this whole thing started
like the museum thing he apparently
comes home from school and he had
forgotten his keys so he was like locked
out of the house essentially so now the
only way to get into the house was they
had um you could get in through the
basement like they usually left this
kind of basement door that was like
outside like uh unlocked just in case
like for such situations
now on the show he says the moment I
walked in the basement I was creeped out
by it I heard this whispering and when I
turned to look in the corner I saw the
eyes those glowing green eyes like he'd
seen in his room and I saw the head and
the scales of this thing
now
I saw like another video of him like
another interview that he was doing
about this later and I don't think that
he said because on the show they showed
him going down into the basement right
and then they showed the basement as
though it looked like an Egyptian tomb
and he didn't say that he saw that I
mean the way that he was talking about
it
he said something like well it was it
felt like you shouldn't be there or I
was in someone else's domain but he
didn't say oh my God I walked into the
basement it looked like an Egyptian tomb
because I think that's something that
you would probably like mention how that
happened
but he didn't say that but that's kind
of what they showed on the show and then
when he said like in the interview that
I saw with him later which like I said I
think was from 2020 or at least that's
when the um video was poked and posted I
think it was paranormal Zone TV or
something it had like a three or four
minute interview with him
he said that when he went down in the
basement he just thought the basement
was creepy and he saw something in the
corner that he just described as like a
black mass he didn't say that it looked
like a blizzard person or anything like
that so I don't so I don't know he's I'm
just saying that there's like different
[ __ ] going on
so um so yeah
so he said that he said this is what he
said
he said it was crocodile in appearance
and partly mutated with a person and
just very massive and very menacing so
he basically said it was like a big
lizard reptile dude like a lizard man
like a slee stack that's the first thing
I thought of like that damn
villain from bat from [ __ ] Spider-Man
and the the lizard what's I think he's
called Lizard Man
that's creative
he's like in a doctor's [ __ ] he's in
a doctor's [ __ ] Smock oh yeah yeah
or the alligator or something I don't
know what he's called I think it's
lizard man
can you just like oh my God you're like
drawing a comic book and it's just kind
of like that's like your villain or
whatever what are you gonna call it oh
lizard man yeah
I think I think Spider-Man was 60s right
now late 60s
they just called [ __ ] what it was yeah
yeah there wasn't any competition they
didn't think of like it yeah it's like
put that Goblin on there okay yeah the
electro yeah
whatever Doctor Octopus yeah dumb kids
will read it yeah yeah the lizard guy
the vulture yeah yeah the vulture yeah
I mean I guess it's easy to remember
yeah but everything was just like so
literal yeah well there wasn't much
competition
although Spider-Man was classic man
really good yeah into green78 said I was
unique too a big old gay hello
I said
or anything like that but I just thought
it was funny like the wording that she
used
like he's always been a very unique
individual it kind of like gave me that
same Vibe it's like you know when you're
talking about something and then like
the other person that you're talking to
like thinks you're full of [ __ ] or like
thinks you're boring or whatever and
says wow that's fascinating it kind of
sounded like that you know what I mean
like she was almost like she was being
sarcastic but not quite that's kind of
like the vibe that it gave me
so uh so yeah so as I said
um he said that he saw this crocodile
looking dude like a lizard person pretty
much in the corn in the basement
um he says it was coming after me like a
creature would stalk prey and so he runs
out the basement as you would
um and he said and this was the point
where I knew that it was something
paranormal
um and he didn't know exactly what was
going on but he knew this thing was like
after him for some reason
so again he tries to sell his parents
but they like think he just has an
overactive imagination or whatever but
it's at this point too like his mom said
well his whole personality or his
demeanor started to change
um she said he wasn't sleeping all that
well and he was like seemed like he was
like angry and frustrated all the time
and you know secretive [ __ ] like that
so
um that's the thing about it too and I
thought this was kind of interesting
they didn't really go much into this it
was just kind of like something they
mentioned and then didn't like mention
again but the mom who they're calling
Susan on the show
she was not so much I don't think she
was so much a disbeliever in like [ __ ]
being a paranormal but she didn't think
it was like um you know a lizard person
or Egyptian god or whatever she says
maybe it's because because remember I
said that this was her she grew up in
this house because it belonged to her
mom and dad and she said that um her dad
was like an abusive drunk and there was
a lot of domestic violence so I'm
assuming that like the dad like beat up
on the mom and maybe the kids that was
the implication and so she was thinking
well maybe like there's some like bad
energy in the house and like my son is
picking up on that like that's why he's
getting so she didn't necessarily think
it wasn't paranormal she just thought
that it was something to do with like
[ __ ] that had happened in the house when
she was a kid like that had to do with
her dad because I'm like assuming that
her dad was dead at this point
so maybe she thought well maybe my dad's
an [ __ ] ghost now and like he's
hanging around in the house or or
there's like a bad vibe in the house and
maybe that's what's making Caleb like
act up or like not be able to sleep or
something maybe he's picking up on that
so I don't know but they she just
mentioned that like one time and then
they didn't like bring it up again other
than like the narrator saying um but you
know that Mom didn't have any idea that
her her troubled childhood is unrelated
to what Caleb is going through and then
it's like then they did a mention again
it's like it's nothing to do with you
Mom stop trying to make it all about you
but um but yeah
so then apparently there's like a lull
in the activity Caleb said he didn't see
anything for a couple weeks but he said
he could always kind of feel it like in
the corners or like in his peripheral
vision or whatever
um he said he tried to like not be in
the house by himself all the time
because he was you know getting freaked
out and then one night I guess there was
like he was in his bed I think again and
he said he started getting sick to his
stomach and then he said there was a
sensation like an anxiety attack like
something was like you know like weight
pressing down on him and then he said he
felt like this searing pain on his arm
he said like it felt like my arm was in
a vice and I didn't think it was gonna
let go
um and then he like pulled up his sleeve
or whatever and he said his arm was
bleeding and he said it very very
clearly looked like a bite mark even
though on the show it kind of looked
more like a scratch like a like claws
but he said that it looked like a bite
mark and that it was bleeding so you
know what I mean I don't know
uh so again he hides that from his
parents so I like how you're kind of
like I wanna I wanna drink too yeah but
I'm like too busy talking yeah oh yeah I
I had to [ __ ] put my mask on I don't
drink it forever
Danny Rowling said uh who would win in a
fight Bane or a Minotaur
pain you think yeah Bane would win well
even if even even before bet even
without venom what Bane would win he was
a lot smarter than a Minotaur
people don't realize how if you go back
read up about the Bane character
of how intelligent he was he spoke a
[ __ ] ton of languages
[ __ ] uh was real good with chemistry
uh he could learn anything uh
and he was all educated in prison
his dad betrayed a government
in Central America and ran so they
captured his little son and threw his
son in prison in his in his place in a
dark prison
but he learned from all the other
prisoners that was in there eventually
escaped
in some stories
he helps Batman
and Other Stories Batman gets killed and
Bane becomes Batman
Bane was the Central American Batman he
becomes Batman in some stories
so he's not a evil character per se not
in all the stories
just um he was a sigma he was not an
alpha he was a sigma male
Alpha gone wrong
Danny rolling said Minotaur uses weapons
though and not restricted by comic laws
yeah
although probably restricted by
mythology laws yeah which is a whole
different thing although are there any
laws in but they use weapons not they
would use weapons that's what I'm saying
I kind of feel like being a problem yeah
these weapons too
well his main weapon was Venom
which is a [ __ ]
in some stories basically a powerful
anabolic steroid that he stole from
[ __ ] Batman Batman was on the juice
God if you've got to understand in most
stories Batman's pushing 50 and you just
can't be built like that with 50 he was
taking strength enhancing serums
that's [ __ ]
comic book [ __ ] speak for [ __ ]
roids man he was [ __ ] jacked
of course Batman's gonna be jacked
he's got money
and he's a mortal man he doesn't have
super power he's jacked well having
money is its own superpower yeah that's
its own superpower having money being a
billionaire yeah and having access to
technology pretty much like the
superpower yeah medical biotech and [ __ ]
[ __ ] Batman was awesome
yeah of course he was Sauced no I'm just
I was I was I didn't know if you were
gonna yeah yeah you were gonna say
something I don't know I never know I
know I like I can't now I can't see your
mouth so I don't know if you're opening
your mouth you know what I mean
all right so where was I okay so uh so
this monster like bit him on the arm
um October says uh something or she said
something about um
uh I'm with Tom on that one I thought
that dude was telling a yarn I get like
this guy yeah yeah but still it was a
good episode it was I was like really
entertained like I said this one I don't
know this there was just like so many
funny moments in this because I was just
kind of like did they really think that
anyone was gonna believe that that would
really that that I mean come on
I thought the werewolf one although it
was the werewolf when that was
Paranormal Witness wasn't it the one
where the werewolves surrounded the
cabin or whatever Paranormal Witness
yeah I'm like this is somebody's horror
movie script that they couldn't sell
right yeah and then so they said well
listen let's take it to a paranormal TV
show they'll put it on yeah they're
trolls you know what I mean that's kind
of that's where I'm going with this one
too I maybe that's what it is maybe he's
like a struggling writer and he's like I
wrote this story about somebody getting
possessed by like a you know a mummy or
like an Egyptian god or something and
nobody would buy it so
I said maybe he's like I'll pretend it's
a true story and then you know how'd
that work out
it worked out they made the show about
it uh so yeah
so again like Caleb doesn't tell his
parents that this monster bit him or
whatever
um and uh his mom said that uh
everything got worse he got depressed
and had uh what she termed an emotional
breakdown and then so they got him
counseling uh because they were worried
about him
um but he still kept like pulling away
from them and like wouldn't talk to them
anymore or anything like that
now apparently this went on all through
high school
um and as soon as he graduated high
school like Caleb got the [ __ ] out of
the house like hoping to kind of like
get away from this monster
um so he went to Glen Burnie Maryland uh
which is several hundred miles away from
Geneva New York where he grew up
um and then he got a job as a security
car security guard at a mall uh Annie
also had got a girlfriend named Laura
and he said for several it seemed like
several years like he just had like a
regular life now he did tell his
girlfriend about being tormented by a
lizard monster
and surprisingly
um she was okay with it like she
believed him and she uh he said she was
very supportive and you know she was
kind of like hey you know I know there's
like weird [ __ ] in the world or whatever
so now that now that he's asked me
Hercules versus Bane I'm gonna have to
give it to Hercules because [ __ ] Zeus
is step in and [ __ ] save him
Hercules Hercules you know of course you
know that it doesn't work that's a
that's a funny that's a funny question
it doesn't work it's two different
universes
you know well that's what I mean it's
like the rules aren't this I mean it's a
fun like it's a fun like intellectual
experiment yeah but yeah the the rules
of the world the rules were a little bit
different
the closest thing that would probably
come close
from from comic books the closest thing
that would come close to [ __ ]
Hercules would be [ __ ] Thor
or Superman those those are Gods
basically
it's a bane wasn't a God he was just
super criminal slash
dark hero kinda
depending on what what who's writing him
uh okay so so yeah so his girlfriend is
all like yeah I totally believe that you
got possessed by you know not well not
possess not until later uh but you got
haunted by whatever this thing is like a
crocodile God or whatever uh she's like
okay that that sounds legit so um also
he befriends this guy who's like a
co-worker of his and his name is John
Sally I think they said Sally like was
his last name
so um so they become friends all they're
the two of them and Laura the girlfriend
are on a camping trip
and John asks Caleb about the scars on
his arm like I said like from the bite
mark that supposedly happened when he
was 14. Caleb is just like um hey I
gotta go get some firewood or something
like that like he totally like changes
the subject but Laura goes all in there
and said well you know do you believe in
the Paranormal because this is like some
paranormal [ __ ] and she like tells him
about it and then John says to them it's
like oh well you know I do believe in
that stuff because I had my own
experience
um and he said that for a long time like
he said his life was a living hell
because he was like
his story was
and this was like a little mini story
within a story but he's like well allow
me to like go back and flash back and
tell you what happened to me when I was
a kid it's like when I was a kid I went
into the woods and came across this old
building which looked like [ __ ]
Jason's Jack from you know Friday the
13th part two and then in one of the
corners was this old book I picked it up
and it was a Satanic Bible because of
course it was I mean you know
what day what was it like the Anton
LaVey Satanic Bible the little paperback
one yeah the one you got the damn B
Dalton bookstore at least yeah at least
they didn't say it was the Necronomicon
because that would have made me laugh
even more
I'm like you know that's not a real
thing right I mean like it's a real it's
a real thing now because somebody made
it a real thing but like when Lovecraft
was writing about it it wasn't like
necessarily a real thing you know what I
mean he just like made it up and then
later on you know
wrote it to like correspond to the
universe but uh but yeah it's not like
an ancient text or nothing like that but
it's funny because I kind of feel like
there's still especially like back in
the day like in the 80s like during the
satanic Panic like they actually totally
thought that was a real thing oh my God
I found a Necronomicon in the woods and
I'm like possessed by a demon or
something like that it's funny no you
didn't don't worry about it
you're fine but um but yeah so
apparently uh so he finds he could have
been one of the lucky kids that found
like somebody's Playboy stash in the
woods but no he had a fun Satanic Bible
instead I guess it happens so um now now
I kind of want to go out in the woods
and likely substitute Bibles out there
just said 20 years from now like
somebody has this kind of story again
that'd be hilarious but uh I'll leave
like I'll leave like a bag of uh vintage
playboys and a satanic bible next to
each other like Choose Wisely yeah yeah
create a whole generation of iron Rand
[ __ ] fans oh God nobody and nobody
wants that
um she was a little coarse
a little yeah yeah I [ __ ] around on my
husband because I could what was he
gonna do about it that's kind of funny
kind of funny attitude well it wasn't
any of his business she um yeah I don't
even yeah
well see that's kind of the the thing
it's like she thought at part she
thought she was a superior being yeah
because she was smarter than everybody
else or so she's I'm like one no you're
not
um and two she was smart though well I'm
not saying she wasn't smart I'm just
saying you're not the smartest person in
the world you're not smart and and even
if you were the smartest person in the
world that doesn't give you license to
like run roughshod over everybody else
on the planet because you're just one
little human being that eats and shits
and dies like everybody else does so get
the [ __ ] over yourself and so that's the
thing though is that it would be
different if she advocated you know just
this complete like selfishness or
whatever and like but you were okay with
everyone else doing that [ __ ] too but
they never are they're just like well I
well I can do whatever I want but no you
can't you have to do what I say yeah or
you have to do what I like and that's
what I mean it's like and it always kind
of goes like that with people like that
they're like oh well I can do whatever I
want but if you do whatever you want
then they get mad especially if you show
me that person hurts them right so
that's what I mean hold on I have never
I and I've met some people like that in
my life and to a man they are always
like that if you did the same [ __ ] if
you treated them the way that they treat
other people they would get really upset
yeah and they'd be like what the [ __ ]
are you doing and I'm just like do you
see that that's what you're but they
don't because they don't have any
capacity for self-reflection yeah and if
you look at Ian Randy and philosophy I
think they call it objectivism I think
yeah but that and then you look at Anton
lavey's religious Satanism they're very
closely alive they are very simple very
close they're very similar yeah and I
think and I'm pretty sure Anton levate
kind of recognized that that yeah well
yeah that was kind of like a big thread
of like like um yeah thought back then
like particular
you know he would have Jesus would have
said yeah well she's writing about this
and that isn't it yeah yeah and I'm not
saying she was wrong about everything
I'm just saying that I mean sure it's a
mixer she was yeah and that's that's
what I mean it's like you you should
just be able to like pick and choose
never just like take one person and like
just take all of their [ __ ] like oh all
of that's true that's no just pick and
choose you know because not everybody
has all the aims there's not not one
person has all the answers European
philosophy especially [ __ ] you know
uh Friedrich Nietzsche and [ __ ]
Arthur uh schopenhauer and uh they had
came up with some really cool ideas and
there's a lot of Truth to what they say
but you just take one of those guys and
get it get off into him it'll drive you
[ __ ] nuts those dudes were nuts they
couldn't they didn't they weren't that
functional
you know
and and a lot and someone a lot of them
died young you know if I can icha didn't
live that long it wasn't his fault you
know syphilis got him
syphilis got a lot of he wasn't really a
philosopher he was more like a
commentator
he did have some philosophy but he
didn't like philosophers he also thought
they were full of [ __ ]
in a way
uh
in some ways [ __ ] well I don't want
to say that but in some ways it's like a
niche was almost kind of like the Howard
Stern of his time he was kind of like
the a shock jock you know especially
when it came to religion
so he was famous mostly for that but he
wrote some cool [ __ ] you know
well that's what I mean I kind of feel
like that's and I don't think he should
throw the baby out with the bathwater
like there is a lot of value in
philosophy but you can't just I mean I I
kind of feel like every not just
philosophers but I kind of feel like all
humans in general
um everyone is just like a mixture of
you know cool [ __ ] and [ __ ] to
varying degrees you know everybody is
full of [ __ ] to some degree DJ's [ __ ]
greatest aspects of his varieties was
the will to power which was kind of like
what you would know today is and I think
was what they used as kind of a basis
for the force and its Dark Side that's
basically what he's talking about
and uh there's a couple good videos on
it that describes the will to power what
it is the power that's behind life and
the and and reality and the different
kinds of relationships objects and
people have
and you know um to each other and
there's a lot of Truth in what he says
and it's uh but
truth is in some ways is limiting you
can be limited by the truth you can
accept something as true
and if you accept it too much and follow
it as a religion it'll [ __ ] your life up
don't worry about it just react
appropriately to a changing situation
navigate the sea
navigate the ocean that's what you do
honestly I kind of
um feel like uh you know being able to
adjust to different circumstances is
really the undersong hero of Personality
flexible right yeah be Gumby yeah I mean
I kind of feel like that's the that's
really the only philosophy you need it's
only when it's worked I've seen yeah
what could because the world is complex
and different situations like have
different circumstances and like you're
gonna have to approach it differently
like depending on a lot of different
factors so you got to be able to like
[ __ ] change around yeah and I've
always found morality to be basically
situational it depends it is situation
it is yeah granther said anytime I meet
a follower of objectivism I know the
conversation is going to be void of the
smallest Joy they are very angry
Superior
overly serious people I have noticed
Grand there's all said I read The
Fountainhead when I was 19. oh what I
would pay now to get those 200 hours
back I didn't read The Fountainhead I
did read Atlas Shrugged though and uh
yeah I kind of wish I could not the best
her best work was Anthem I like that one
and it's a short story taking place in a
dystopian future that just kind of lays
out
objectivism and collectivism in the the
problems with with collectivism are you
taking that you're taking the faith off
I would read Anthem it's a short because
it's short it's short it's not like yeah
because like The Fountainhead and Atlas
Shrugged or [ __ ] door he's not a good
novelist well that's the thing it's not
a novel it's a polemic
I mean you know if you're gonna write a
novel write a novel it can have a theme
or a message fine but it's like at least
make it like an entertaining story don't
just make it this [ __ ] philosophical
slog if you want to write that just
write that don't like couch it in the
terms of like making a fictional story
Anthem is just made me want to slap her
Anthem is just like a quit morality tale
there you go okay and then it lays out
things at the very end of what it means
it tells you what it just told you
almost kind of a very Buddhist kind of a
[ __ ] uh method of teaching I'm going
to tell you I'm gonna tell you and then
I'm going to tell you what I just told
you yeah exactly what it does
it's an effective teaching method well
honestly that's kind of like um I want
to say that that's kind of like how some
of my English teachers taught you to
like write uh an extramarines essay
because they'd just be like well you
know because you got to do the
introduction of the body and the
conclusion they're like that's basically
what you're doing is you're telling
people hey I'm gonna tell you this I'm
telling you this I just told you that
the end you know what I mean so it's
like it sounds dumb but it's like it is
actually kind of how [ __ ] is like laid
out you know what I mean
uh but yeah so well I forgot where I was
okay so so John this friend that Caleb
knows uh also said you know yeah he came
across Satanic Bible and apparently
there was a little demon
that was uh that attached itself to him
like a tick after like they didn't say
that on the show I just said that but um
from the Satanic Bible he opened it up
and he's like oh [ __ ] now I have like
[ __ ] Lyme disease except with a demon
so the demon attaches itself to to John
uh and he was eventually uh freed of the
demon
by good old Deliverance Minister which
is what he calls himself uh spoiler
alert it's Bill Bean who has been on
this show before who like I said I
really feel like he's gone in for uh the
Warren's Throne on these shows because
not only did they I mean I can't
remember the name of the episode but
they did an episode about Bill Bean that
was all about Bill being like when he
was a kid like supposedly like growing
up in the house and everything and they
said oh and then he grew up and became a
Deliverance Minister like help him you
know
kind of like chisel off like people's
demons and whatnot so uh but then like
he also was involved in some other cases
later on just like the Warrens were so
like they do a case and they're like oh
and then by the way Bill Bean showed up
and so this was one of those
so uh so yeah
so John uh the guy in here later became
Bill Bean's assistant and helped him
like cast out demons from other people
and whatnot because he had gone through
it and the real John was on here and
Bill Bean was on here too for like a
couple minutes
so December of 2013. uh Caleb goes back
home to his parents house for the
holidays and sleeps in his old bedroom
uh for the first time like since he got
the [ __ ] out the house like and got away
from the monster or whatever
now the first time that he's back in the
room he hears whispering in there and he
said in the name that I kept hearing
whispered over and over was so big
and because he didn't know anything
about Egyptian mythology he had to go
Google it uh and he said as soon as I
typed that name in everything clicked so
what they said on the show was that
Sobek was an ancient Egyptian deity uh
that took the form of a crocodile
um and the show said he was worshiped by
the ancient Egyptians as a protection
entity to protect them as they traveled
through the afterlife which is
kind of accurate but not exactly like
what it says on uh Egyptian I think the
site was called Egyptian museum.org
what it says about Sobek is that Sobek
was among the oldest deities named in
the pyramid texts the text inscribed on
the walls of tombs he was the lord of
the crocodiles and was depicted with a
crocodile head some ancient Egyptian
sects believed that Sobek created order
in the universe and the world when he
arose from the Dark Water quote unquote
and that he was the creator of the Nile
River
he was often associated with fertility
Sobek was revered for his ferocity and
his quick movements however he was an
unpredictable deity as were his
crocodile counterparts he was sometimes
associated with chaos the people of
ancient Egypt worshiped Sobek in order
to appease both him and crocodiles in
general please don't eat me yeah um and
also to ensure the fertility of their
people and crops so I don't know if he
was so much like an afterlife deity as
hey crocodiles don't eat me and hey
nature deity like yeah more like a
fertility kind of deity and that's not
an evil deity not really no well I kind
of feel like that's what's kind of cool
about ancient religions that's why I
think I was always kind of drawn more to
like Greek mythology Egyptian mythology
is that they're Gods like humans were
multifaceted like he didn't really have
just like oh that's an evil one or
that's a good one like they all were
changeable like humans were like
depending on the situation yeah and this
one is basically a crocodile it's just a
thing in nature it might eat you you
might want to uh bribe it so it doesn't
eat you yeah and that makes total sense
but it makes the it makes the water and
it also helps reproduction so you know
it's part of nature it's good that's
what's in general right it's helping
nature to me that seems like a lot more
that's what it means close to what
nature is actually like yeah than trying
to like impose order on it from above
which I feel like the judeo-christ
religions kind of tried to do I kind of
feel like ancient religions like I said
maybe that's why I relate to them more
is like they saw the world as it was and
they just kind of like constructed a
mythology that had to do with that like
I said it's made sense because if you
grew up in ancient Egypt yeah you could
get eaten by a crocodile so crocodiles
were unpredictable you probably saw them
all the time sometimes they would eat
you but sometimes they'd leave you alone
so you know he's capricious yeah you're
not trying to rationalize it you're not
trying to moralize it it's random yeah
that's and it's like nature yeah and
they're just trying to like get a handle
on that like I said that's totally
understandable so so to me I don't know
like the ancient beliefs and stuff like
that make a lot more sense to me yeah
just because you can tell where where
it's coming from it's kind of like a
one-to-one he's like yeah they would
think that these guys are Christian
they're they're uh projecting their own
uh beliefs onto it it looks like a damn
crocodile so therefore that's like it
did it's bad that's like that's like the
dragon right out of [ __ ] you know at
a revelation or something and so it's
it's got to be bad and you're worshiping
it and you're not supposed to worship it
so it's bad that's yeah see it's just
it's just so black and white like I said
I think that ancient religions they were
a lot more open to
ambiguity because like I said that's
kind of like what nature was like
because they were like well
they made Gods like people yeah I'm
gonna say you're partially right because
Christianity does this also well yeah it
does right but especially I'm
simplifying yeah you're simplified
because Catholicism does it a lot
especially in in the Americas you get
into Central and South America they have
things like soap
Sobek they have things like that it's
just going to be recast as a saint or
some kind of an Angelic deity right
something like that
um you know like you know Brazil had its
own and then it's going to be not might
not be something in the official
Catholic Church it might be something in
condom ble or macumba which is also kind
of yeah to me that seems like closer
like I said that's kind of like right so
they're still doing this yeah they're
they're but they're just not going to
call it a god
although they didn't really consider to
God either you know the Egyptians are
not saying that this thing created the
universe it's a Pantheon it's a Pantheon
the father of the Gods created his
children and then he created and then
the father of the Gods created the world
and his children did things in it right
and uh his in it usually involves his
children knocking up Mortal women and
making demigods
that's in there too and and and and uh
kind of apparent monsters like Minotaur
and
Medusa or whatever things like that yeah
although Medusa liked I think she's made
a different way yeah well she was super
beautiful like when she started out she
got turned into a monster by one of the
Gods because she was [ __ ] around in
one of the goddesses temples okay and
the goddess got pissed off and said I'm
gonna turn you into a monster right that
turns everyone you see into stone right
so which is why this is really
interesting when I was watching some of
the Medusa um you know makeup tutorials
one of the things a lot of the um Medusa
makeups will do is they always make her
like crying because she's like a I mean
she's a monster but she's like a tragic
yeah character because she didn't want
to be a monster obviously one of the
goddesses got jealous of her because she
was [ __ ] around and the goddesses
Temple and said I'm gonna turn you into
a horrible monster all this [ __ ] is
everything you hear in these old
religions exists in the Bible too it's
just that you're not really seen it the
right way you know like like for
instance what was Samson
you know he's doing Supernatural Feats
it has to be a Nephilim yeah his his
father has to be one of one of God's
Sons
the ones that chose the Mortal women to
have that saw them beautiful in other
words his father was an angel
it's like it's like the Marvel Universe
but the BCE Edition right
I'm in a great Renown they were giants
in the earth you know that's a Nephilim
yeah well the
the the the Greeks had those too you
know like uh that would have been uh
any any demigod spawned by Zeus's Sons
and Daughters if Zeus spawned one that
would have been Hercules which is that's
what Jesus was
that's where he did the father of the
Gods had a child through a mortal woman
and there goes Jesus okay yeah Jesus and
Hercules there are a lot of them
Hercules you got Zeus
fooling around on Hera with them [ __ ]
mortal women again and boom there turns
up into a swan and whatnot [ __ ] man you
know how women like to [ __ ] screw the
squads you know and Bros hey that's
that's someone's fetish yeah that was
another thing or a shower of gold which
I'm not even sure how that happens how
do you [ __ ] a shower of gold it was that
that was that's easy it's just like it
just pours into your [ __ ] yeah I'm
gonna tell you how that happened in the
like glitter you can never get that [ __ ]
out in the modern world that's a woman
falling down on the ground and a whole
bunch of [ __ ] cryptocurrency
yeah she's just [ __ ] hitting the
[ __ ] rules look at my [ __ ] ATM
[Laughter]
you know what's weird it's like now that
you say that like every time that I
every time that I read that story about
Zeus in the shower of gold yeah I I
never thought of like a share of gold
coins for some reason I always thought
it was like a share of like gold glitter
like I thought it was like gold or
something yeah like I thought of like
gold dust rather than like yeah yeah I I
think it might have been cool because
I'm like I don't want to have sex with a
bunch of gold coins I think it was coins
and Nuggets it's money
you know how to hoes like money you know
I like who likes money
they got [ __ ] homemade [ __ ] porn
and [ __ ] those girls [ __ ] roll around
on a whole bed so [ __ ] cash and dudes
throwing cash on them and [ __ ] them
and [ __ ]
big booty girls
and that's the video and then all I can
I know I get in a big pile of cash but
see I'm because you know I don't know if
it's real cash it might be
it is so dirty yeah I mean I would hope
that it was just like paper money like
hundreds that was clean and sanitary
because all I can think of is just kind
of like man you're just gonna like if
you gotta like all these coins you gotta
like pick them out of your butt rub on
her knees or stacking all this [ __ ]
hundreds on the top of her booty how
much money they can stack on her booty
because she's literally sitting on a
[ __ ] gold mine it's just naked
[ __ ] money coming out of the internet
that's what they're doing money just
coming out of the Internet it's falling
on her ass
it's a good idea to make a [ __ ] good
video
oh don't don't pretend you haven't
already seen one like that I've seen him
that's awesome yeah you're gonna star in
one am I yeah where are we gonna get all
that money when they start sending them
Super Chat that was good
[Laughter]
it's making it rain I'm making it rain
yeah you see how I like making it rain
all the [ __ ] you say yeah I'm just
saying like for I don't know why I just
never thought of it as like a shower of
gold coins I just thought of it as like
a shower of gold like glitter like gold
dust that's what I was like yeah Oracle
Zeus was kinky as [ __ ] man Zeus would
transform himself into a bowl
and come from the [ __ ] imagine that I
can see that more than a swan though and
evidently
seducing the woman in the form of a bull
as long as he didn't turn himself into a
duck because they got that Corkscrew
dick yeah
I mean it works for like a female duck
because they have like a corkscrew shoe
vagina they were imaginative people back
in those days
that was another thing I always liked
about Greek myths I kind of feel like
that was one of the things that kind of
steered me toward atheism when I was a
kid because I started like reading Greek
myths when I was a kid and I was just
kind of like man these are super cool
because I'd known Bible stories like
since I was little my family's not
religious but
um you know I had I had like books of
Bible stories that other like relatives
gave me and stuff but when I started
reading like Greek myths I'm like man
this is much cooler yeah this is a lot
more creative Jeff ER says I recalled
Old Testament angels and the same
temperament as ancient gods many of them
had hair triggered tempers and could
demolish entire city yeah
it clearly says
that El Shaddai all right which is
Father of the Gods
had I think they said I think it was 72
Sons
and each one of those sons was given a
tribe
Yahweh chose Israel there's a bunch of
other ones that are mentioned later on
out of those Suns
uh it tells it tells you do not or
Yahweh told Israel do not sacrifice your
children
to um you know what was his name Molek
you know and basically later on it says
you're first born or mine
yeah so original baby yeah
originally Yahweh demanded Human
Sacrifice but that got [ __ ] kind of
reversed later on with the Abraham and
never mind it's like nah let's not do
that anymore and there's a lot of baby
killing it's so ghost yeah there's big
there's there's evidence for it they
find these little urns with little
sacrifice to babies that's [ __ ] into
those areas they were doing that [ __ ]
up might be kind of like birth control
but also it was first born of all your
animals too it wasn't just your children
first born of [ __ ] sheep and the
firstborn of this whatever the firstborn
was had to go back I don't know man I'd
be like you know you're a God why you
need my [ __ ] make your own [ __ ]
come on you got magic powers it's gonna
be kind of like it's going to be kind of
like the uh uh make your own baby kind
of like the Aztecs uh blood debt having
to repay the blood debt because every
time something's born it's stealing
blood from the [ __ ] solar disk from
God
so when you [ __ ] up or your capture
whatever it's your duty to be sacrificed
so the blood can go back so new people
can be born and so you're not you're not
draining the sun's blood
the same thing
yeah don't want to be draining the sun
you know what I mean yeah but
um it never under any circumstances says
anywhere in the Old Testament that other
gods don't exist it says they exist
says don't worship them
yeah that's what I mean that's implicit
like in the Bible it's not saying oh
that's the only God there is it's like
no there's a bunch of them right but
this is the right one yeah and it's
telling you you're reading this book you
must be one of the tribe of Israel if
not you're not reading this so it's for
you Israel this is coming from Yahweh
later on
Yahweh assumes the position of God later
on in Exodus
the burning bush tells Moses your
ancestor your ancestor Abraham knew
Mizel should die okay but you but you
know me as Yahweh
basically is what it says
and I am your Baal because it mentions
Baal too I'm also Baal so Yahweh
is also Baal it kind of means Lord
but uh Bale was another bad [ __ ]
okay
so somehow in that religion they said
okay by the way this whole El Shaddai
cult they're not in charge anymore it's
now a cult of Yahweh and uh Bale you
guys that worship Baal you're you're
with us too it's the same God that's
what it's saying
because usually in these old pantheons
the father of the Gods is overthrown by
one of his sons
you know like [ __ ] Zeus came to Power
by overthrowing he became God when he
overthrew Kronos
it was his father
and he was evil
so that's kind of what happened to this
El Shaddai was overthrown by Yahweh
doesn't quite say that but
God or father of the Gods is a title you
can you can take like the throne I've
now have taken the Throne of God
well I did a lot well I kind of feel
like the reason that's a recurring Motif
in a lot of those things because that's
what happens in real life yeah life in
heaven in his own Earth yeah because
like you know you get old and you get
like usurped by the younger generation
so that's why that keeps like occurring
like in stories like because people see
what's happening and they just like make
up stories they have to explain why some
Cults are dying out and other Cults are
growing and taking over yeah you know
I'm just saying that humans like
throughout history and all around the
world like have are similar you know
what I mean like they they come up with
like similar [ __ ] like given similar
circumstances yeah they're going you
know we'll call to molec man they're not
around anymore that was 100 years ago so
I guess we're in charge
you know that's that's what they're
saying right you know
so they got to reboot the tail reboot
reboot yeah
Jeffy art said the ceasing of sacrifices
was probably due to an increase for a
tribe's population yeah uh Zach just got
here out of Tom Rod there's a monster
something uh gonna eat you
oh it's just I'm assuming you met Jenny
but you put Kenny yeah uh great costume
thank you very much I had to take off
the glasses you could get the full
effect because like I said see I got
contact
I don't know if they're sideways though
I can't really see it
I was gonna like not bother because I
thought maybe you wouldn't be able to
see it then I was like [ __ ] it I bought
these so I'm gonna like put them on
I suffered for it so I'm gonna wear
um but yeah so let's see
so yeah we were talking about uh Sobek
so
oh I didn't even finish that okay so um
worshiping so back in order to appease
both him and crocodiles in general like
I said crocodiles don't eat me also to
ensure fertility the people and crops
many mummified crocodiles of all ages
and sizes have been found in Egyptian
tombs so you know there's that uh so
back was associated with both Seth his
father and Horus whom he helped birth he
was also considered to be the Army's
Patron because of his ferocity so like I
said I kind of feel like on the show
they're not entirely wrong like what
they said about Sobek but because
they're coming at it from a Christian
perspective obviously anything that
looks quote unquote ugly or like a
monster like because he has a crocodile
head
um Christians are gonna see that as
satanic but like I said that kind of
happened as like Christianity like took
over they took like all the pagan gods
from before which were not explicitly
evil like you know you had stuff like
pan or something like because it was
like a lot of half human half animal
kind of hybrids that was like a big
thing but they always like specifically
said oh well all those are evil even
though that was not the case like I said
I kind of feel like the old pantheons
none of the gods were like explicitly
evil they all had like they all had
different facets to their personalities
like a person you had evil demigods and
stuff that would appear but then they
usually got killed
I don't think there was a Satan per se
no in the
not the way not the way people would
understand because like I said that's
the thing once once Christianity became
established I mean that's a very
I mean depending on the iteration but it
is like a very black and white kind of
like you know this is good these are God
and the angels and blah blah and then
you have like Satan and demons and
that's like always bad but that's not
the way that ancient religions like
understood the world I don't think
that's how how uh actually I don't think
that's how ancient Christians well well
no but I'm talking about like as it I'm
talking about like after it became
established it's just that church when
most people who are religious today are
actually not following the Bible they're
following Church Traditions yeah nowhere
really in MO well okay in the Old
Testament there is no Satan per se
Satan appears in heaven before God
saying I saw your
your favorite one job and he's down
there loving you and [ __ ] but that's
just because you bless him yeah that's
because you're nice to him yeah if you
[ __ ] him up he'd probably be like [ __ ]
you yeah he says you give them to me
I'll test him and [ __ ] I'll show you
he'll turn on you and he says okay go
ahead and do it I'll take I'll take your
challenge do it just don't kill him you
can't hear he's okay but you can do
whatever else he does all kinds of [ __ ]
too
see I've read that story as a kid and I
was like man that is a [ __ ] up [ __ ]
Satan Satan in in the Old Testament is
not a devil okay he's in heaven
he's he's God's prosecutor yeah he's the
main prosecutor
the god of the Old Testament
is not the god really as described in CR
in in the New Testament the god of the
Old Testament is a demiurge which means
a devil God he's God and Devil combined
okay he tells you what to do if you
disobey you [ __ ] annihilates you okay
he punishes you also there's no real
it's mostly it never mentions hell it
just says sheol which is the [ __ ]
grave death
there doesn't seem to be any concept
really that a good follower goes to
heaven a good follower goes to the Grave
some of them are allowed to go to heaven
I think Methuselah was allowed to go and
humans were never met for the heaven
humans were meant for Eden okay so going
to heaven that's where the Angels were
you were never promised that yeah they
knew why humans like stinking up the
place come on no that's like going to
Mount Olympus they're talking about
Mount Olympus yeah humans didn't go to
Mount Olympus we don't want you [ __ ]
anymore you obeyed and then you got you
just obeyed and died that's it okay so
there was no real kind of reward per se
in the Old Testament in the New
Testament
there is devils and demons but they
usually possessing people
later on in in what you call it there's
a beast which is a man in in Revelations
and then there's the Dragon
the dragon doesn't seem to be Satan
either the dragon seems to be they seem
to be referring to Tiamat Tiamat was was
the was a Celestial Dragon
that earlier religions uh what was his
name Marduk slayed Tiamat and cut her
body into pieces and from that the
Universe was created yeah and people
believed in Tiamat okay
that their Universe was made from the
body of Tiamat that was the old [ __ ]
tale that was kind of people believed so
what they talk about is the dragon being
thrown into the lake of fire at the end
what they're talking about is they're
saying that God uncreates the universe
is what they're talking about I'm
starting off that's it there's no more
Universe yeah no more creation there's
only there's only a new Eden that's it
in heaven
and it's it's about restoring humans to
Eden in the form of this [ __ ] big
celestial
Kingdom on Earth that's what they're
talking about in in in in in in in
at the end of Revelation
you're given new bodies where you're
Immortal but you're living on this new
Eden
not in heaven
so but Church Traditions are going to
change all this uh they're they're
telling another narrative that isn't
there
which is real common well I mean they're
just basically kind of like and people
do it nowadays
um you know you pick whatever out of the
Bible that you want that that matches
with your already like ideas that you
already already believe in right so
there's like the I mean because it's so
all over the place and there's so many
stories in there and there's so many
contradictions that basically whatever
you believe you can find something in
there that's going to support your [ __ ]
so and most of the Christian writings
were thrown out they're not in the Canon
no the the councils threw them out and
we don't know what most of them are we
got a few of them but Thomas book of
Thomas but um and none of that [ __ ]
really fits together all four gospels
tell a slightly different story well I
mean like centuries apart yeah they all
have different endings there's different
authors they were never meant to be
presented together in a single narrative
they were single books that were sold
separately it's a selected works also an
accessories yeah they put them together
and they harmonized them to kind of make
a narrative sort of but it's rough yeah
it's a very rough narrative
and it wouldn't fly in any screenwriting
class yeah yeah that's what we're saying
in the Old Testament is also super rough
it's
Genesis is at least three books [ __ ]
woven together
at least three
there's three different creation events
told
so you know
it's it's complicated I'm [ __ ] done
with that [ __ ] I mean they try yeah
they don't want to throw anything good
out they said don't throw that out save
that wait that shit's good yeah yeah
just put that in the next it doesn't
make sense with that but we'll kind of
maybe smooth it over good and the reason
being is because they're trying to
harmonize a bunch of different
Traditions a bunch of different
Jewish Traditions they're trying to
harmonize them
and you're going to have people in there
saying you can't throw that out man that
one's too popular it would be the same
as [ __ ] having all the different
versions of the Batman comics all right
and everybody's got their own family
favorite ones and you're trying to make
one Batman story at all like one
narrative like one new thing all the one
yeah it's exactly the same it's exactly
the same so they're going [ __ ] we can't
throw this out because man Bane [ __ ]
tears it up in that [ __ ] story we
gotta keep that one even though Batman
is slightly different in that story it's
the exact same thing if you're big into
[ __ ] comic books you will you will
know mythology it's the same thing
comic books are mythology yeah and
religions are the only difference that
nobody believes that comic books are
real yeah yeah everybody knows that it's
stories you know what I mean uh
according to the [ __ ] Roman writings
and [ __ ] most people knew that that most
well yeah I think that's I I think it's
a misconception that everybody believed
that stuff was real back then they
didn't they didn't believe it was real
no I mean some people did yeah but like
a lot of people most people didn't
believe it knew that that was just like
mythological story yes yes or stories
that were just like that you know that
nothing against them just like you know
just to
kind of like teach lessons and [ __ ] like
that they didn't have movies they didn't
have TV and they didn't have nightclubs
right they had those temples they didn't
have anything and they did all that you
paid to get in a cover charge basically
they called an offering and they put on
any kind of show you could which
included sex drugs music yeah okay for
certain Cults Bacchus was all about
getting [ __ ] blasted well yeah that's
why that [ __ ] was that's why and when
you went to those temples you're
basically going to a rave yeah
that's essentially what it was other
ones were definitely sexual fetishes
statue of this woman that can [ __ ]
shoot [ __ ] milk on her titties and
they're [ __ ] it's some kind of breast
fetish thing can you imagine like going
to that you'd be like
a hole down because man that's a whole
sub genre foreign
lactating women would go and dudes would
come to [ __ ] drink breast milk and
[ __ ] it was uh they're giving offer
and they're paying to go in there to
drink and then the girls are giving up
milk for some religious reason you know
what I mean probably thinks that it make
him have more babies or something like
that yeah I imagine it's probably like a
fertility yeah fertility because like I
said more coming out of your titties
that's like that's pretty
fertility I forgot the name of that list
but they had a lot of those old things
and it's cake some of that [ __ ] was cake
well yeah you just couldn't call it that
back right I mean at least nowadays like
I said they did they do the same [ __ ]
that people do nowadays but at least now
like people know that that's what it is
like that it's a fetish back then they
were kind of like trying to pretend that
it was something yeah
[Laughter]
they weren't just like saying what it
was like I just get off on this there's
like a reason for it right it's the
[ __ ] like nowadays you could do it
nobody'd be like all right Fair enough
but like back then you had to have
invent like a whole justification they
had regulars which like you know [ __ ]
dude you've been coming here for years
oh yeah
oh my God
yeah and grampers points out uh there's
no Satan in Judaism just the tempter or
accuser yeah and that's initially yeah
that's initially what the Satan was he
wasn't
because I like I said I kind of feel
like even modern Christians are just
kind of like Satan like thinking that
it's this evil
you know like an evil being but that's
not like how it originally started out
there are demons
you know but the demons seem to be
fallen angels or Evil Dead spirits of
Evil Dead it can be either yeah there's
a lot of evidence that in in the New
Testament that early Christianity was
many Cults they were all different they
all had their own stories they're all
revolving around Jesus and half of them
were exorcism Cults about casting out
demons it says in many places Jesus man
these other Chris Christians on the
other side of town they're casting out
demons in your name and we told them to
stop oh no don't do that man they're on
our side go tell them yeah cast out
[ __ ] demons
have demons and [ __ ] you know what I
mean that that's what it's about they're
casting out demons a lot of the stories
about cast now Davis
what's up this episode of a haunting was
also about castle Yeah casting out demon
cult is what it is that's what Christian
part of Christianity was that
and it still exists yeah yeah the
Baptists and [ __ ] do it yeah they do
that yesterday yeah
yeah they still do it well like I said
you know you can say that um a lot of
this stuff is kind of like old hat or
whatever but I was well I was just
watching a video other day
there's
um there's a channel on YouTube that is
like these couple like super super
Christian girls they're like young
they're like in their 20s or something
and they come on like just very
authoritatively like telling other
people how to live the most Christian
Life or whatever and the one they put
out the other day they were talking
about
um Halloween costumes they didn't seem
like super against Halloween although
they did have that weird like
fundamentalist Christian thing where
they think oh Halloween is like
celebrating the devil which whatever
um no but you know but some that but
some like like I said like a lot of
fundamentalist Christians have that so
they're basically like well you can
still celebrate they kept calling it
Harvest you know what I mean because you
know like churches will do Harvest
Festival well you can still like wear a
costume but it has to be like you you
know this sexy thing why do girls think
that it's okay to like just dress up
sexy this one time a year even if you're
a Christian like they dress up like that
and I was just like watching this like
are you guys for real holy [ __ ] yeah and
they're also kind of turning their back
on that most of Christianity especially
early Christianity was about increasing
women's sexual value yeah a lot of it
was about that it uh because it was
saving women for prostitution increased
to their sexual value they could get
married trying to restore a woman to a
[ __ ] a sense of a status of being a
virgin so she can get married they did a
lot of stuff like that yeah I know so
yeah this isn't what they're talking
about Instagram 78 said you should hear
those crazy girls views on drag queens
uh yeah I I can imagine honestly I don't
watch their videos like I'm not going to
give them any views but I watched them
on uh Nick deramio he has a channel
where he's always kind of like he said
he doesn't just pick on Christian stuff
he picks on a bunch of different stuff
but he's like [ __ ] hilarious and he
has kind of just recently like latched
onto these girls channel so sometimes
he'll go in there and like [ __ ] with
them and uh so I watch his video about
their videos with people like that is
that they
Christians like that is that they their
Baseline is that there's only one
Christianity totally untrue from the
very beginning there are many of them
well they don't seem big on Nuance
that's kind of the problem Christianity
was never one thing it was a bunch of
competing Christian Cults and they're
still competing Christian Cults now
they're just going to call them
denominations and different churches and
[ __ ] but they're Cults a bunch of each
one of them has their own little little
belief system their own ethos their own
style
um there's nothing wrong with that you
know I mean there's nothing wrong with
being a cult it's just a small religion
that's all it is there's no difference
between a big one and a little one just
the size there's only difference
but it's that's not they're not unified
and they all believe in something
slightly different they're going to tell
you a different narrative a lot of
having to do with what who the church
Founders were who their Church fathers
were you know and what they wanted and
what their interpretation was most of
the stuff about Christianity is not in
the Bible
it's all in the extra canonical stuff
you know like uh what early church
fathers did that kind of stuff that's
where a lot of the Traditions come from
well and a lot of Saint Thomas of
Aquinas did a lot of stuff is like a
relatively modern yeah like you know
it's not that old it's not really as old
Roman Christianity would have been
unrecognizable to a modern Christian
okay we're like that's Christianity like
yeah yeah that's what it was I've kind
of well I've kind of come to the belief
that like the people that are the the
biggest hardcore Christians have not
actually read the Bible all the way
through because I think they because
they say some [ __ ] that I'm like yeah
but that's in there though yeah
do you not know that or
you know what I mean it also for every
time it says something like okay here's
an example
in like a Pauline material
it'll it'll
power is Powerball and or somebody will
ask Paul is it okay for us
if we're with Romans
and they invite us to their home for
meals
can we eat meat
with them that they sacrificed
to a Roman God can we eat that
and
Paul will in one place say oh well as
long as you know that you're a Christian
and you know that those Gods aren't real
it's totally okay that you eat that
they're just God won't smoke
in another book
that kind of comes up like if you ever
eat any [ __ ] meat don't you [ __ ]
sacrifice to a pagan God God will Smite
you for you know this [ __ ] like that
yeah so wait a minute hold on
well which is it just don't go to anyone
else's house ever right it means they're
more than one author yeah that's what it
means well obviously in all Saint Paul
but it's it it's more than one I mean
navigating all these rules that just
sounds [ __ ] exhausting it's it's
exhausting like stupid little rules like
that well here's okay
here's one thing here's an example like
from my own life because this is
something I had some experience with
when I was in Elementary School uh back
in the 80s or 70s and 80s
um I knew a kid who was a Jehovah's
Witness like mainly like I didn't really
know anybody that was super religious uh
where I went to school
um but this kid when I was in sixth
grade he was uh well his parents were
Jehovah's Witnesses but he was like a
really nice kid and everything but the
thing about it was that every time we
celebrated a holiday or someone's
birthday in the classroom like somebody
would bring in cupcakes or whatever the
[ __ ] it was
um he had to leave like he had to go sit
in the teacher's lounge which all the
rest of us kids thought was really
shitty I'm like well that's one religion
I won't be converting to that's for sure
can't even have any [ __ ] holiday
cupcakes but then it got me thinking
even when I was like 11 12 years old I
was like okay yeah but what if I just
hypothetically brought in cupcakes on
just a random ass day that weren't like
decorated like you could eat those so
it's like what if I just brought in
random cupcakes one day and it happened
to be a holiday like Valentine's Day or
something like that but I said oh well
these aren't Valentine's Day cupcakes
they're just cupcakes I brought in
because I forgot that it was Valentine's
Day like can you eat those or will God
Smite you yeah and I was like are these
the kind of things they're thinking
about all the time because I'm like that
really sounds exhausting I got no
problem with Christianity I'm not
anti-religion the problem is when you
take the [ __ ] too seriously and you try
to rash you try to codify it into one
thing because there's too much stuff
there there's too much material that's
why there's no way nobody could live
like that yeah because a lot of the
rules are like contradictory right yeah
and that's why there's different
churches it's because the the the church
fathers of those churches have
reinterpreted or said no we're not gonna
worry about this we're going to focus
more on this there's methodists and
other you know kinds of different
versions of Christianity and even
different versions of [ __ ]
protestantism the problem is when you
take it too seriously he's trying to be
become well the problem too is when you
try to enforce it on other people yeah
that don't want nothing to do with that
[ __ ] that never happened
granther said uh the horniest girls are
fundamentalists they know they need to
get the devil [ __ ] out of them
well and they go through the loophole
they'll do anal because then technically
they're still virgins I think a lot of
that is uh of course you know sexual
frustration being pent up you know well
obviously yeah it's not just
Christianity it's all [ __ ] strict
religions are like that they get pent up
well anytime anybody is raised in any
kind of strict thing whether it's
religious or otherwise yeah you're gonna
bust out of that because it's just kind
of like right like you're gonna like man
I must be sinful because I'm thinking
something so you know yeah yeah because
that's the thing and I'm not saying that
people should just be able to act on
whatever the [ __ ] you know flits across
their mind because obviously we'd all be
in trouble if that happened but you know
to to an extent like like I said as long
as everyone's consenting I don't really
have a problem with anything that people
are doing if you want to get into some
freaky [ __ ] and everybody is on board
with the same [ __ ] fine do it and it
doesn't hurt me none it pretty much in
any kind of extreme thing thinking can
become like a religion too even if it's
non-theistic
Buddhism is kind of non-theistic there
isn't a God in it really in in most
versions of it
but it can become a a kind of a dogmatic
religion so can philosophies and
political ideas well I mean anything can
if you're already inclined to be that
way yeah there are dudes that are into
this [ __ ] um I mean I'm not inclined
to be that way so it doesn't make there
are dudes that are into like
self-improvement
meeting Girl science where you have
these gurus that [ __ ] teach them how
to meet girls and they'll follow the
[ __ ] to the T like that's a religious
Dogma yep and they'll defeat themselves
by doing that of course so because
they're because they're coming at it as
if it's a system as if it's the system
and like [ __ ] there's not a system yeah
like I said you have to just be flexible
because shit's different and navigating
the waters yeah yeah that's that's what
I mean it's like anything that you're
like well you have to follow this little
letter and then this will happen like
XYZ was that like the world doesn't work
like that yeah like like mathematics
maybe works like that
um you know some hard Sciences maybe
work like that but literally nothing
else does very male thinking that it is
that there's a system and that it's a
machine we'll see that's kind of nothing
and I and I kind of got into yeah
because um yeah that's the POA the Pua
uh pickup artist yeah you know kind of
sub code which is related to the incels
it's like they're they're different kind
of stuff but um yeah the whole pickup
artist subculture there yeah there are
guys like selling these really expensive
like books and conventions and stuff
like that yeah
where they're basically like look if you
do XYZ yeah you know to a woman then sex
will come out you know what I mean it's
like if then it's like a goal it's a
little bit extreme they most most of
them don't say that
but that's at heart that's what it is
when you back off that's what it is look
at the whole system as it wants it's
kind of looks like a machine yeah like
like I'm putting
um you know some money and I'm putting
niceness and I'm putting like a nice car
and stuff like that into a vending
machine and then [ __ ] will come out
yeah that's basically what they're
thinking yes and I'm like that's not how
it's not that simple [ __ ] works oh [ __ ]
works but some of the stuff that they
say is true have good hygiene
[ __ ] well that's just true of
everybody whether you're looking to date
or not just like Yeah clean your ass man
look as good as you can look as good as
you can [ __ ] uh be as successful as
you can uh have as much money as you can
all that [ __ ] will help you all right
well yeah I'm not saying that yeah yeah
like be confident like keep yourself
clean like [ __ ] like that like that's
just I mean that should be a baseline
standard nowhere everybody know what
women like you know that kind of stuff
well and I would also Advocate and we've
talked about this before I would also
Advocate not approaching things because
if you approach things like a
transactional agreement then most women
will get very very pissed off at you and
you might not understand why but it
because we know what you're doing yeah
I've listened to some of some of the
guys though and some of them say don't
do that they're saying don't do that
they're saying just improve yourself
some of it's very general
oh and I don't have a problem if all
you're saying is like work on yourself
yeah make yourself a better person make
yourself somebody that people would want
to hang out with like not just women but
like anybody like that like anybody want
to hang out with make yourself just
cooler to be around and then people and
then women will come naturally yeah and
in my experience you know I [ __ ] I'm
successful with women uh got pictures to
prove it Jenny knows but Jenny Jenny too
you know I mean she's a successful
person the um
there was no system it was it was just
having fun and from that kind of comes
charisma it success feeds on success I
can understand how some guys who just
get down into a hole and they can't get
out of it yeah and then it's a
self-defeating like it gets after a
while like I get that I get how it
happens like you fall down a rabbit hole
like yeah and then if your body goes
down that rabbit hole with you uh not
women are visual just as visual as guys
I have [ __ ] grafters ask me do women
like big titties on men because he's
looking at how thick my chest is a woman
will say no
most people will say women don't care
about muscles the truth is
women don't like bodybuilders and when
they say bodybuilders are talking about
ifbb [ __ ] guys that are [ __ ] up on
Olympia that's a full-time job
that dude can't go out and have fun his
diet doesn't require it all he does is
work out sleep and take steroids okay
and eat
he got no time for a relationship that's
what I mean that's his [ __ ] job all
right which like I said if you want to
do that that's fine but like don't
expect like women to be like because
it's like yeah it's like that dude's
never gonna like have any time for me or
time to do anything the truth is that
there's diminishing returns you can get
so big that you're not attractive
anymore and a lot of those if you want
to see what women do like go back in the
1960s you know and and look at
the top guys are good-looking guys from
1960s that did Bob they weren't that big
they just well they didn't look they
didn't weird they didn't look like
freakish right they didn't look freakish
they just looked like a hood ornament
really what they look like thin waist
broad shoulders big arms
and muscle definition square jaw
it's just pretty much the same of today
nowadays they wouldn't even call his
dudes bodybuilders they call them
fitness model really
so do women like muscle yeah yeah
now grab your [ __ ] chest you know
um but but that doesn't mean anything
really because they don't know you
if they get to know you they don't like
you that muscle then then it doesn't go
then it's not gonna make any difference
what you look like nope
because like you said yeah to an extent
women are visual but I think women have
a lot more going on like they well they
have a lot more to lose uh for one thing
yeah you know and you just they
generally don't like to hook up with
randos I mean some women do but there's
a lot more to lose if you do and what I
describe will only happen when women are
in a crowd there were crowd with a bunch
of their [ __ ] girlfriends yeah
because they have backups it's not like
you're gonna have like some random woman
just like walking down the street or a
coffee shop that's by herself that's
gonna come up and do that [ __ ] I don't
if somebody does that she's probably
like a hooker or she's on meth or
something yeah no no normal woman is
gonna do that
they're in a club party situation and
they're [ __ ] got 20 friends with them
and yeah and they're just all out having
a good time and they're probably like a
little inebriated yeah right and they're
all just doing it's like oh I'm gonna
grab this dude's titty you know what I
mean it's like oh they're being wild but
it doesn't like you said it doesn't mean
anything no and when it happened to me I
had that mask on which means I was
depersonalized right all right if I
didn't have that mask on they probably
wouldn't they would have said oh that's
a person they might have but I mean I
don't know how drunk they were I didn't
see them yeah because I had that mask on
I didn't I didn't come across as a
person because they couldn't see your
eyes yeah right
yeah yeah that helps too same thing
happens at Disneyland we know people
those people with the in those costumes
women will just grab them go Prince
what's his name Valium just grabbing him
and [ __ ] and he's like you can't touch
me you can't touch me
well sometimes like like teenagers and
stuff will just come up and like punch
him in the dick yeah yeah because like
you said you don't think of that as like
a person in there because you can't see
them yeah right they're just like
wearing a big costume right so and but I
think that that's kind of why well and
even going back like a long time like
why people enjoy like big festivals
where people are wearing costumes
because everyone's depersonalized so you
get away with a lot more because you
don't feel like you're de-individuated
yeah you know what I mean so just part
of this you're anonymous you're
anonymous you're part of we saw that
happen like I said Saturday night
Halloween because everybody was I mean
there was zillions of people out and
like everybody was well most people were
dressed up and so people were acting a
little bit wilder than they normally
would yeah like if they were just going
around with their regular assets sure
asked people feel and that's like that's
been studied over and over and over like
if you have a mask on then it's easier
for you to do [ __ ] up [ __ ] and it's
easier for you to do [ __ ] up [ __ ] to
somebody else that's also wearing a mask
because you don't see them as a person
you can't see their face you can't look
in their eyes you can't judge them right
you don't like they didn't know how old
I was they didn't realize that I'm old
to be their father
right you know yeah they just saw the
arms and the mask and stuff like that
and like I said they were it was just in
passing like I said I didn't see it
because you just told me later and I was
like I stopped you were like didn't you
see that I was like I was I was I was
like looking over there like I said
probably looking at the floor make sure
I didn't trip or looking at somebody
else's costume or something like that I
didn't even notice what like what was
going on but um or something or it might
have been what was it when we were going
out under the back patio back Patty oh
okay because some guy like was on the
stripper pole yeah well he was like up
by the triple and he like leaned over
and he said oh my gosh your costume is
amazing so maybe I was like talking to
that guy and like I didn't see oh okay
before we got there it was halfway down
through the bar on the outside and I
stopped and I said you see that okay it
was like it was so loud and then I
looked at the girl and she's [ __ ] she
can't see my face but she's smiling at
me like yeah I grabbed your titty
now they better grab my [ __ ] table
yeah I'll punch you right in your mouth
unless it's an accident like yeah I
don't like [ __ ] do you want to see
how much meat was there okay how much
meat was there
yeah American Military 100 said women
can be visually stimulated but it's more
cerebral than Optical yeah I mean like
like I said women are a lot more
complicated as as you know now that
you've done those uh [ __ ] now now
you've kind of experienced a little
taste of like what where it's all the
time yeah what women think like [ __ ]
when your progesterone level goes super
hot this weird [ __ ] that I've done
they're [ __ ] crazy they're [ __ ]
crazy a male would consider that [ __ ]
uh insanity
you just have no [ __ ] confidence
no yeah you're just like what well
that's why something wrong just that
year and like I said welcome to my world
you're almost kind of compliant in a
weird way and you're uh
but when you're on this [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] going up and down that's Trend
you know the trend is notorious for it
but see like I told you yeah that's kind
of like yeah coming I mean I don't like
it that's just and I'm aware of it but
it's like I don't you know that's just
you can't really get it's hard to get
out of it you know what I mean because
that's just kind of like what your how
your program sort of like you know like
I said to a greater or lesser extent
everyone's the same obviously but it's
just funny that the couple women that I
told that that you were being like that
they all of them just said oh like we
have every day and I was like yeah
it's real unusual for a guy yeah
yeah well like I said maybe you'll
understand now like why no I understand
why why we have such problems yeah I see
it because I told you I told you like
seriously and uh you know what's weird
frustrating yeah I know tell me about
tell me about it
um because like I said I I'm like that
and I'm aware of being like that and it
makes me mad but it's like I can't like
change it all that much and that's very
very frustrating yeah but it's weird
because I saw like somebody commented
this the other day and this is something
that I um just on some random like
article I don't remember what it was and
this is something that I've thought to
myself and again this is like really
really General
um and you kind of said something like
this earlier
like uh you know something goes like if
you're a man and like something goes
wrong in your life or something like
that generally most men will be like who
can I blame like this is somebody else's
fault
um or it's the outside circumstances
fault uh woman's case something goes
wrong this is my fault somehow always
it's always your fault yeah
um either you did too much you didn't do
enough somebody even if there's no
possible way that it could be your fault
a woman will blame herself yeah and I
know that's not right I know but I mean
sometimes it's true yeah I'm doing the
same [ __ ] sometimes it's true but um but
women will that's their default you will
you immediately the first thing you do
is like what did I do wrong yeah what
did I do wrong for me mostly it was
coming off a trend like a trend
withdrawal is it the hormonal crash
you're like I [ __ ] failed you know
like I said I'm like yeah I have I have
that like every day every day my life
[ __ ] sucks every day everything I did
was wrong but you start going down a
damn [ __ ] you yeah you start going to
war with yourself yeah I didn't live up
to my expectations yeah that kind of
[ __ ]
yeah now you know what it's like yeah I
was inferior now you know what it's like
right I failed this because they didn't
choose me right kind of [ __ ] you know
they didn't choose me because I wasn't
good enough right yeah every single
thing yeah you're like yeah there's no
hope
you know but then your the demand in you
is trying to go well I will retaliate I
must become an Unstoppable machine but
then then you get bit beaten back down
again right and [ __ ] that's kind of
what women go through yeah yeah I mean
like I said we don't go quite as far as
I'll become an ensemble machine but we
go somewhat in that direction or at
least I do like you get down to a point
where you're just like oh my God I suck
like I [ __ ] this up and I could have
done this better like why haven't I done
more stuff blah blah blah and then like
you know you might get a little bit of
hope you'll be like oh well you know I
shouldn't beat myself up and it's like
you know maybe I can do this maybe I can
do that I can fix it blah blah blah but
then we I mean I like I said I've never
gone so far as to be like man I'm
[ __ ] awesome I've never had that yeah
and I know that a lot of dudes have that
but that's generally not a thing that
women think we always think there's
something that could be improved there's
something that could be better or that
we [ __ ] something up always on a trend
stack you got a superhuman levels of
[ __ ] testosterone very little
estrogen you can't really sleep or go
into REM sleep too well and a [ __ ] ton
of [ __ ] progesterone that's not
supposed to be there
so you're the most confident [ __ ]
arrogant narcissistic [ __ ]
self-deprecating [ __ ] loser you could
ever your [ __ ] Ultra [ __ ] Godlike
and super insecure at the same time and
it's [ __ ] weird and then when it goes
away you're like I'm a loser you know
what I mean like and it's it's but it's
not it's not permanent it's temporary
the this part of it is evidently only
gonna last like a couple days yeah
American Military 100 said very true
females will internalize yeah we
internalize pretty much everything
um everything foremost everything that
happens like it's my fault somehow yeah
well and you know even if there's no
possible and even though intellectually
I know there's no possible way that
could be my fault but you still somehow
feel responsible I'm still bumping a
[ __ ] ton of tests she's still feeling
I'm still bumping a [ __ ] ton of tests
even though Trent is gone I could not
imagine what it would be like to have
low testosterone right now
oh yeah [ __ ] but like I said you know
this is kind of like
yeah I mean this is kind of like what I
experienced like every single day like
you're never good at Netflix like I'm
not smart enough I'm not pretty enough
I'm not this I'm not it's just like
every like all the time and you try to
talk yourself down from it but you can't
it just keeps coming back all the time
all the time right now I'm on like 400
milligrams of test
that ends up being like [ __ ] three or
four times with a 20 year old what an a
grade 20 year old has
it's probably like 1600 nanograms per
deciliter price something like that
kick I said uh AAA saying I'm an
egomaniac with an inferiority complex
yeah yeah it's temporary though it's
just something the trend does to you
like I said I have the inferiority
complex covered but I don't I don't
think I'd I'm not an egomaniac Tran was
not not intended for human consumption
before for this reason it's very
effective though you just can't get that
kind of shape so quickly without it
yeah Mark says I wonder if that voice
that tells us we suck or we failed or
we're undeserving it's like a jungian
alternate alternate personality coming
out
I don't know I kind of feel like that's
kind of my main
thing that's kind of like like I said
that's kind of like my default mental
state and it's aggravating because I
know I think it's hormonal well no
because I know like that a lot of times
like I have a tendency to like overthink
things and I have a tendency to like
overdo things and it's like oh I'm doing
too much and nobody cares that much and
all that other stuff but I can't I don't
know it's really like you said it's
really really frustrating because you
kind of feel like you suck and you need
to do this that and the other and
whatever you do is not good enough but I
don't know it's just like a constant
[ __ ] women struggle women were never
androgenized for [ __ ] testosterone
they didn't go through male puberty
and
when a woman hits menopause it's
recommended they should take 20
milligrams of tests to kind of hold and
hold them together
keep their metabolism running at a
normal rate so they don't put on a bunch
of weight
and I found that that 20 to 25
milligrams
works well and most doctors will say
that
one time she got a little bit too much
by accident
and she felt exactly like she does now
with a lot of those same mental progress
processes that she's talking about
but she'd be angry
well that's why I told you I didn't want
it anymore I said that's just making me
feel like as shitty as I usually feel
except now it's making me a rage monster
on top of that yeah because I already
have anger issues like without that so I
don't need like that exacerbatch what
instead instead of that what that would
have done to a male because they're
androgenized for it would have given a
lot more confidence no all right for a
female it's just maybe more
insecure more Angry yeah that's all I
did it just made me feel worse you want
to keep testing in a post-menopausal
female you want to keep test around 20
milligrams that's about it
uh the only thing that a woman can do on
top of that
would be five milligrams a day Winstrol
but only for a few months
the one they can do for a long time is
anavar I think it was seven milligrams a
day or something or 14 twice because
it's got a real short half-life and that
produces no test there's no real
androgenic there's a little bit but not
much it's not very androgenic but they
can take a pretty good amount of that
it's very effective and it does nothing
to a man I've taken anavar makes it feel
good but it doesn't make any changes in
you not physically
Zach says I'm annoyed at always playing
the Peacekeeper role and bottling up my
emotions and then I always feel bad for
expressing them even though I always
also feel like I'm not dealing with them
properly yeah I get where you're coming
from I get where you come from and like
I said that is um yeah that's something
that I have it's I'm like a very
conflict diverse person so I don't
really like to kind of um b-roll blunt
with people usually because I don't want
to hurt anyone's feelings even though
maybe sometimes their feelings deserve
to be heard in some cases like or maybe
they need a wake-up call but I don't
really like to do that like I always
kind of like to be nice and you know try
to keep peace between everybody because
I don't really like anybody getting in
arguments or fights or anything like
that
um but then like I don't know so that's
probably not good because then like you
still like are building up like all
these emotions and resentments and stuff
like that and then like it'll bust out
like later on because it's got to come
somewhere Mark says uh yeah me too I
overanalyze everything yeah me too
it's a double-edged sword because I can
be quite prepared for a lot of
situations and other people's BS but I'm
constantly beating myself up yeah it's
the same thing it's like I don't think
that I would want to be different
because I feel like the only reason that
I get as much [ __ ] done as I get done is
because I overthink things and because
I'm always beating myself up like I'm
not doing enough I need to do more I
need to do more so I do get a lot more
accomplished that way I feel like if I
just went the other way and said oh
don't worry about it then I'd be like
super lazy and not do [ __ ] you know what
I'm saying it's dark up we're gonna
start get trick-or-treaters okay well I
didn't even like finish talking about
the show okay
um we're gonna have to wrap it up pretty
soon I mean we just kind of got well I
mean there wasn't much left like I said
we were still talking about so back and
then uh long story short like Caleb got
possessed by Sobek apparently even
though it didn't make him turn into a
crocodile creature which would have been
awesome but uh he basically just turned
into a douche that had a green contact
lenses much like mine it looked like the
same contact lenses I think it might
have been
and um yeah so he comes back from the
house and Laura's like what the [ __ ]
matter with you like he's all like oh
you can't help me remember and she's
just like okay well I'm fine whatever
um and basically she's like he seems
like a stranger uh John tries to do an
exorcism on him or a Deliverance I guess
they call it they don't call it an
exorcism I guess that's a different
thing and uh and it doesn't work like
the spirit is too powerful for him so
he's like there's only one person for
this job Bill Bean so he calls Bill Bean
up and then Bill Bean comes in and
basically he comes in and like within a
minute he's like uh he's just like yeah
Jesus blah blah like get out of there
like you demon or whatever and then he's
like yeah and then I just saw the demon
like leave through his mouth the end
um and basically yeah it was like very
anticlimactic this episode especially
like considering how
I mean he's supposedly possessed by an
ancient Egyptian crocodile God you'd
think that would have like a more epic
finale but I guess not but no Bill Bean
came in and sorted that [ __ ] out like in
a minute and uh that was pretty much the
end of it I did forget like the whole
point where he was getting like super
hostile when he was quote unquote
possessed by the demon and he worked as
a security guard right
and uh he said at one point oh I think
the doorbells ring
um and uh yeah because it's starting to
get dark it's because holy [ __ ] it's
seven o'clock but yeah he started to get
like super hostile and there's like one
guy just [ __ ] standing by the door
and like
um you know he's just like smoking a
cigarette like doing nothing and him is
like a security guard he's just like
what the [ __ ] is this guy doing I'm
gonna kick this dude's ass blah blah
it's like dude um he's just smoking a
cigarette like please calm down uh but
yeah so I know we don't like talk too
much about the episode I guess we kind
of did but yeah so basically bill being
like did the [ __ ] and the thing left and
then you know uh in April of 2014 Caleb
and his girlfriend got married and uh
everything was puppies and rainbows and
unicorns and whatnot like I said um I
found like another video about this guy
like later where he was talking about
the same thing but the weird thing is he
said that he had been uh haunted by this
crocodile demon situation since he was
in third grade which would be like what
eight
eight nine years old something like that
which is not the impression that they
gave on the show The Impression they
gave on the show was that he went to the
museum and saw the mummy and that's when
sobik took over but according to this
other thing that he did where he didn't
even mention going to the thing and
seeing the mommy or anything like that
um he said that he started seeing this
crocodile just inexplicably like in his
room like when he was eight and also he
said that the thing that happened in the
show like with him getting locked out
the house and then like going in the
basement and seeing the crocodile
whatever he said that happened when he
was 12 even though on the show they made
it seem like all of this [ __ ] happened
when he was 14. so I'm not really sure
like why they changed all that [ __ ] up
and like I said he didn't really like
much in the museum or anything like that
but yeah so I guess trick-or-treaters
are starting to show up because I heard
the doorbell just a second ago and Tom
had to go down and give some candy so I
guess we're gonna have to wrap it up
this actually went on like longer than I
thought so that's pretty good I was
almost at three hours so hopefully you
guys have a good rest of your night have
a good Halloween everybody uh be safe
out there don't eat too much candy but
you know I'm gonna eat some candy
um Louie says Jenny saw a decent movie
on HBO Max the night house oh I really
liked that actually um I did a review of
it uh probably last month or the month
before
um but yeah it was really really good I
liked it a lot so yeah go back I don't
remember when it was but I did do like a
review I think it was on flickers of
fear about it um but yeah Jeffrey art
says happy Halloween so happy Halloween
everybody uh have a good one this is my
favorite holiday of the year I'm gonna
go get some candy and maybe get another
drink and then maybe watch some scary
movies or some [ __ ] like that so
everybody have a good one and we will
see you guys again probably tomorrow
um talking about a movie but I don't
know which one it's gonna be
so that's what we'll do so thanks
everybody for dropping by thanks for
your super chats and we'll see you guys
again tomorrow good night